CONVENE THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON COMMUNICATIONS AND
CONVEYANCE- SERGEANTS PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND
NOTICING THAT THERE IS THAT WE
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM I'D LIKE TO
START- THE COMMITTEE AND THE
SUBCOMMITTEE MEETING JUST TO
MOVE THE CONVERSATION FORWARD
THERE ARE SOME RULES. AND
REGULATIONS THAT I GOT A THAT I
HAVE TO SAY IT'S A LITTLE BIT
LONGER BUT THERE NEEDED TO BE
SAID TODAY JUST BEAR WITH ME A
GOOD AFTERNOON- WE'VE NOW
CONVENE THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON COMMUNICATIONS A CONVENIENCE
WE ARE PRACTICING SOCIAL
DISTANCING HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE
BUILDING CAPITAL THAT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. SO WE'RE ONLY
ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED AMOUNT
OF PEOPLE WHO. WATCH HERE AND
PARTICIPATE IN PERSON WE'RE
ALSO REQUIRE THE MAST BE WORN
AND PHYSICAL DISTANCE BE
MAINTAINED. BY ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND THE VIDEO CONFERENCING
ROOM. WE HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT
OPTIONS FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY
TODAY PUBLIC TESTIMONY OPTIONS
INCLUDE TESTIFYING. FROM THE
HEARING ROOM. OUR PHONE. SITE
ON THE PHONE OR VIA THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION ON THE NORTH
SIDE OF THE CAPITOL. AS A
REMINDER ALL MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING. AS IS
CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DISRUPTIVE MAYBE REMOVE THE
CHAMBER OR THE REMOTE MEETING
ROOM- OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS
MUTED. FOR THE PUBLIC IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC. EYE IN
THE ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
ON THE BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR
HAND I'LL ASK YOU TO PUT YOUR
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. I WOULD ALSO ASK THE
PUBLIC NOT TO TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. FOR THE DOLLAR AND
WITNESSES. WE WILL ALSO BE
USING A MODERATE A TELEPHONE
SERVICE. THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL.
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR- FOR
THIS HEARING IS NOT REPEAT
TWICE YOU CAN ALSO. GO TO. OUR
WEBSITE- AND- FIND THOSE
NUMBERS. IF YOU MISS IT HERE
AND THAT NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN I REPEAT THAT AGAIN.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE
ACCESS CODE. IS TWO FOUR TWO
SIX. TWO THREE SEVEN. ONCE
AGAIN THAT ACCESS CODE IS TWO
FOUR TWO SIX. TWO THREE SEVEN.
YOU CAN ALSO FIND US ON NUMBER
ON THE ASSEMBLY COMMUNICATIONS
A CONVEYANCE A WEBSITE AS WELL
AS YOUR TV SCREEN. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOU'RE TESTIFYING IS BEGINNING
THE PRESENTATION. YOU WILL BE
PLACED ON HOLD UNTIL YOUR TIME
AN OPPORTUNITY PUBLIC PROVIDE A
COUPLE OF MONTHS COMMENT COMES
UP. PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE- THIS INCLUDES
MUTING THE LIVESTREAM
BROADCASTING YOUR SMART DEVICES
TO REDUCE A SOUND DISTORTION I
WILL ALSO NOTE THAT IF YOU KEEP
IT ON YOU WILL BE OFF. A TIME
HERE SUPPORT SUPPORT OPPOSITION
I WILL BE BLENDED ON TO THE- TO
THE PHONE LINE PLEASE ALSO BE
ADVISED IF YOU ARE A MAIN
WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR
OR AGAINST THE BILL YOU WILL
REMAIN ON A LIVE LINE IN NEED
TO MEET YOURSELF UNTIL YOU'RE
CALLED ON TO SPEAK. IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATOR PHONE SERVICE YOU
CAN. CALL THE COMMITTEE AT. I
REPEAT THIS TWICE NINE ONE SIX
THREE ONE NINE TWO SIX THREE
NINE. SEVEN NINE ONE SIX THREE
ONE NINE TWO SIXTY SEVEN AND MY
STUFF WILL BE THERE TO HELP YOU-
IF IT HIGH ALSO WANT TO NOTE
THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO THE- TO THE
POSITION- LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. MY FINAL
POINT THE ASSEMBLY HAS
EXPERIENCED A NUMBER OF
DISRUPTIONS IN THE COMMITTEE.
AND FLOOR PROCEEDINGS LAST FEW
YEARS. CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS
DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE IMPEDE
THE ORDERLY CONDUCT IN THE
HEARING IS PROHIBITED SUCH
CONFLICT MAY INCLUDE. REMOVING
A MASK AND REFUSING TO PUT IT
BACK ON. TALKING OR TAKE OR
MAKING LOUD NOISES IN THE
AUDIENCE. UTTERING LOUD
THREATENING AND ABUSIVE
LANGUAGE AND OTHER DESTRUCTIVE
ACTIONS TO ADDRESS ANY
DISRUPTIVE CONDUCT I'VE- I WILL
TAKE THE FOLLOWING STEPS OF AN
INDIVIDUAL DISRUPTS OUR HEARING
PROCESS. I WILL DIRECT THEM TO
STOP AND WARNED THEM THAT I
CONTINUE TO SUBSTANCE MAY
RESULT IN THE REMOVAL OF THE
CAPITAL. YOU THEIR REMOVAL. OF
A CAPITOL BUILDING. I WILL ALSO
DOCUMENT FOR THE RECORD THE
INDIVIDUAL INVOLVED IN THE TO
DISRUPTIVE CONDUCT- I MADE
TEMPORARY RECESSED THE HEARING
IF THE CONTINUES. IF THE
CONDUCT IS NOT STOP ALL REQUEST
A SYSTEM FOR THE SERGEANT ARMED
IN A SCHOOL AND INDIVIDUAL FROM
THE CAPITAL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
THE MAN
SECATEURS WE'RE GOING TO
PROCEED. ON AB. SIX SIX ZERO-
MISTER COOPER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BURST SB SIX SIXTY AS
DELIVERY NETWORK COMPANIES TO
LIST OF ENTITIES REQUIRED TO
ROLE IN THE PART REMOTE PARTS
DEPARTMENT MOTOR VEHICLES
EMPLOYER PULL NOTICE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU. ANY ANY MAIN SUPPORT
WITNESSES. NO NOTED ANY
OPPOSITION SUPPORT WITNESSES
NONE NOTED UNLESS THERE'S ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION WITNESSES IN THE
CHAMBER. ANY MAIN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WITNESSES- ON THE
PHONE. OR IN HEARING ROOM. ANY
CLASIFICADOS SAVES. OPPOSITION
OR SUPPORT ON THE PHONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND WE DO
HAVE A LINING QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE EIGHTY
EIGHT ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
EIGHTY DID YOU WISH TO SUPPORT
OR OPPOSE AB SIX SIX ZERO.
THERE ARE NOT ALIGNED IN Q.
PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK YOU
UNFORTUNATELY CAN'T TAKE THE
MEASURE UP AT THIS MOMENT
BECAUSE WE'RE IN A QUORUM SO
WE'LL TAKE IT UP- ONCE WE
ESTABLISH QUORUM THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRS THAT WE
HAVE TO HAVE A- ALTHOUGH WE
DON'T HAVE A CORNIA. YEAH WHEN
THEY COME A COMPANY. THANK. NOW
WITH A GROUP OF PROCEED AB
FOURTEEN- MISS AGUIAR-CURRY
COMMUNICATIONS BROADBAND
SERVICES THE CALIFORNIA
ADVANCED SERVICES FUND LITERACY
CLASS. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. ONLY TWENTY
MILES FROM OUR STATE'S CAPITAL
IN THE SACRAMENTO VALLEY THEIR
CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE NO ACCESS
TO BROADBAND CONNECTIVITY AND
THE ESTIMATED FINANCIAL NEED TO
DEPLOY BROADBAND IN THIS SMALL
REGION ALONE IS IN THE HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. THERE
ARE IN FACT CONNECTIVITY
PROBLEMS IN URBAN AND RURAL
AREAS THROUGHOUT THE STATE THE
TECHNOLOGY STATE. ONE IN A
CALIFORNIA HOME STILL DO NOT
HAVE INTERNET ACCESS AND SMALL
TOWNS RURAL AREAS YEAH
COMMITTEE COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
FACE EVEN HIGHER NUMBERS OF
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES WHO
REMAIN DISCONNECTED UNDER THE
CURRENT STANDARDS. AND THE FCC
IS CONSIDERING RAISING THOSE
STANDARDS AS WE SPEAK.
FURTHERMORE THE ONGOING COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS MADE MADE
GLARINGLY CLEAR HOW CRITICAL
CONNECTIVITY IS IN THESE TIMES
OF EMERGENCIES INCLUDING THE
MASSIVE JUST TRANSITION OF
STUDENTS LEARNING FROM HOME.
AND DURING THE STATE'S RECENT
DEVASTATING DEVASTATING
WILDFIRES. XCELERATED NEED FOR
BROADBAND CAN NOT BE IGNORED.
THIS THAT IS WHY I'M PARTNERING
WITH SENATOR GONZALEZ AND TWO
DOZEN OF OUR HOLDINGS AND I
THINK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR
YOUR JOINT AUTHORSHIP TO
ADDRESS THE DIGITAL DIVIDE IN
THE STATE. OVER THE PAST MONTHS
WE'VE WORKED TOGETHER ON A
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE THAT WILL
MODERNIZE STANDARDS. AND UPDATE
THEM AS THE FCC STANDARDS
EVOLVED TO ADOPT NEW SPEEDS AND
TECHNOLOGY. OUR BILLS BOTH
PROVIDE ELIGIBILITY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED SERVICES
FUND FUNDING AT TWENTY FIVE
DOWNLOAD THREE UPLOAD WITH A
BUILD OUT OF TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
FIVE. AB FOURTEEN PRIORITIZES
THE DEPLOYMENT OF BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE IN CALIFORNIA'S
MOST VULNERABLE. UNSERVED AND
UNDERSERVED RURAL AND URBAN
AREAS WHILE OPENING THE DOOR
FOR A LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS TO PROVIDE
CONNECTIVITY IN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES. WHERE THE PRIVATE
SECTOR CANNOT OR CHOOSES NOT TO
PROVIDE SUFFICIENT SERVICE. AB
FOURTEEN PROVIDES FOR AN
EXTENSION OF THE SURCHARGE ON
TELECOM SERVICE M. BONDING FOR
YEARS WHEN APPLICATIONS EXCEED
THE INCOMING REVENUE TO BUILD
PROJECTS OUT. WELL WE CONSIDER
THE EXACT METHOD OF EXTENDING
THAT SURCHARGE PERCENTAGE
ELSE'S IN AB FOURTEEN OR A FLAT
RATE UNDER S. BEFORE. WE
ANTICIPATE THAT WIRELINE
CUSTOMERS BE WILL ACTUALLY
DECREASE. MY BILL ENSURES
GRANTS ADMINSTERED BY THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION ARE
AWARDED TO APPLICANTS WHO ARE
WILLING AND ABLE AND QUICKLY
AND EFFICIENTLY CONNECT
HOUSEHOLDS COMMUNITY ANCHOR
INSTITUTIONS SMALL BUSINESSES.
AND EMPLOYERS BY MAKING
ELIGIBLE ACRE INSTITUTIONS
ALONG THE PATHWAY OF THE
PROJECT. SO WE DON'T MISS
OPPORTUNITIES TO PROVIDE
LINKAGES TO HEALTH. EDUCATION
PUBLIC SAFETY AND EMERGENCY
RESPONSE FACILITIES. MEMBERS OF
THE PANDEMIC LAID BARE WHAT
WE'VE BEEN WORKING. FOR WHAT
I'VE BEEN WORKING ON FOR OVER A
DECADE TO FIX. TOO MANY
CALIFORNIANS MOST OF THEM WHO
NEED THE MOST HELP DO NOT HAVE
THE INTERNET TO SUPPORT THEIR
HEALTHCARE TO SUPPORT THEIR
EDUCATION TO SUPPORT JOB
TRAINING TO SUPPORT THE
MAJORITY OF SMALL BUSINESSES.
WHO WORK FROM THE HOME TRYING
TO COMPETE IN TODAY'S DIGITAL
ECONOMY. WE HAVE ALSO WE ALSO
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY CREATE
THOUSANDS OF JOBS FOR MORE
CALIFORNIA WORKERS WHO WILL
NEED TO HAVE THE SKILLS AND
TRAINING. TO DELIVER THESE
PROJECTS. AND AS WE WORK WITH
MISTER SPEAKER AND THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THE FINAL
PACKAGE. I'M EXCITED TO
CONTINUE OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES AND
COMMUNICATIONS WORKERS TO
ASSURE CALIFORNIA WORKERS
BENEFIT FROM THESE HIGH PAYING
CAREERS THE TECHNOLOGY
INFRASTRUCTURE. A GREAT MANY OF
US HERE ARE WORKING ON
DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF THIS
FIGHT. TOGETHER WE BUILT THE
MOMENTUM TO SUCCEED THIS YEAR.
NOW IS THE TIME TO SEIZE THE
MOMENT AND BRING ALL OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS INTO THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY FOR THEIR WORK.
THEIR HEALTH AND QUALITY OF
LIFE. TODAY I WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS TRISH
KELLY ON BEHALF OF THE ALL THE
VISION. AND EDUARDO GONZALEZ ON
BEHALF THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
REGIONAL BROADBAND CONSORTIUM
AND FRESNO STATE. THANK YOU. WE
WILL WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
MAIN SUPPORT WITNESSES AS
STATED- MISTER- GONZALEZ AND
MISS KELLY. GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME SAID A LOT OF ON SITE
IS REPRESENTING THE CULT THE
OFFICE OF COMMUNITY AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY PRESS. WHICH
ADMINISTERS THE FALCON VALLEY
REGIONAL BROADBAND CONSORTIUM
THAT'S WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP OF SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY. AS MENTIONED BEFORE ONE
IN CALIFORNIA'S HOMES ARE NOT
CONNECTED TO THE INTERNET
ALLOWS SIX PERCEPTIBLE IN THE
PAST SEVERAL MONTHS A
CONSORTIUM WORKING CLOSELY
WITH. LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS AND
PARTNERS HAVE IDENTIFIED MORE
THAN SIXTY FOUR THOUSAND
HOUSEHOLDS IN A COUNTY REGION
WITH LIMITED OR NO ACCESS TO
BROADBAND. THESE HOUSEHOLDS ARE
BOTH IN URBAN AND RURAL LOW
INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS MAKING THE
BROADBAND DIGITAL DIVIDE A
CALIFORNIA AN EQUITY ISSUE
TODAY I'M HERE TO ASK FOR YOUR
ABLE TO SUPPORT AB FOURTEEN US
STRATEGIC SOLUTION TO
CONNECTING STUDENTS FAMILIES
AND BUSINESS OWNERS WHO REMAIN.
DISCONNECTED UNDER CURRENT
STANDARDS IT BROADBAND HAD A
TIME IT IS NOW. BUT HOW CAN WE
FIX CALIFORNIA'S BROADBAND
NEEDS WHAT MENTAL BUNDY AND
CONTINUES PRAYERS TO DEPLOYMENT
CREATED BY THE PRIVATE SECTOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
WHERE THEY LIVE THEIR
DEMOGRAPHICS AND HOUSEHOLD
INCOME ARE ENTITLED TO THE SAME
PRIVILEGES THAT YOU AND I. HAVE
WHILE GETTING ONLINE AND
SECURING AN ADEQUATE BROADBAND
SPEED APPARENTLY THAT'S NOT
WHAT THE PRIVATE SECTOR
BELIEVES. DUST THIS IS WHERE AB
FOURTEEN COMES TO PLAY OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITY AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS WOULD HAVE THE
ABILITY TO PROVIDE CONNECTIVITY
TO THEIR OWN COMMUNITIES WHERE
THE PRIVATE SECTOR CANNOT OR
CHOOSES NOT TO PROVIDE
SUFFICIENT SERVICE. AB FOURTEEN
PROVIDES FOR AN EXTENSION OF
THE SURCHARGE ON TELECOM
SERVICE AND TWENTY FOUR YEARS
ADDITIONALLY ASMENTIONED AP
FOURTEEN INSURANCE GRANTS
ADMINISTERED BY THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION. OUR WATER
TO APPLICANTS. WHO ARE WILLING
AND ABLE TO QUICKLY AND
OFFICIALLY COME ECTOPIC. USING
METAL MILE TO LINKAGES NOT-
ONLY FOR HELP EDUCATION ACT.
PUBLIC SAFETY ANIMAL WERE ALSO.
TWENTY REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR APRIL. THANK YOU-
MODERATOR- MISS KELLY PLEASE.
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON BROADBAND
LEGISLATION OVER THE YEARS
ALONG WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA AND OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WE ALSO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AG WE ARE CURRY FOR HER
DEDICATED LEADERSHIP TO BRING
CRITICALLY NEEDED BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE TO OUR CAPITAL
REGION AND STATEWIDE AND FOR
HER COLLABORATION WITH CENTER
GONZALEZ AND MANY OTHER
MEMBERS. VALLEY VISION MANAGES
THE CONNECTING CAPITAL AREA
BROADBAND CONSORTIUM FUNDED BY
THE TUC TO CONNECT 98% OF THE
HOUSEHOLD IN OUR REGION WHICH
INCLUDES ALMOST TWENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND HELPFUL HE ALSO
MANAGES SACRAMENTO COALITION
FOR DIGITAL INCLUSION ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO THE
LIBRARY THE WORKFORCE BOARDS
CBO AND HIGHER EDUCATION. SO WE
SEE ALL ASPECTS OF THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE WHICH IS HUGE AT THE
CURRENT RATE OF COLLECTIONS FOR
THE UC CALIFORNIA ADVANCED
SERVICES FUND IT WOULD TAKE
DECADES TO MEET THE 98% GOAL IN
ALL REGIONS ACROSS THE STATE
WHICH IS WHY MANY DIFFERENT
FUNDING SOURCES ARE NEEDED BUT
WE CANNOT REACH ARE
LEGISLATIVELY MANDATE MANDATED
98% TARGET WITHOUT CONTINUED
CALIFORNIA BED SERVICES
FUNDING. THE FUND IS
OVERSUBSCRIBED DEMONSTRATING
THE HIGH DEMAND IS NOTED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AG WE ARE CURRY
TO GAP IN OUR REGION IT'S
LARGER WOULD COST A MINIMUM OF
ALMOST FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS JUST TO CONNECT OUR
UNSERVED HOUSEHOLDS NOT TO
MENTION THE THOUSANDS OF
UNDERSERVED HOUSEHOLDS IN ARE
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
URBAN AND RURAL NEIGHBORHOODS.
WE SUPPORT AB FOURTEEN BECAUSE
IT WILL PROVIDE THE CONTINUED
INVESTMENT IN HIDING AFTER
STRUCTURE IN BOTH URBAN AND
RURAL AREAS EXPAND FUNDING
ELIGIBILITY INCLUDING FOR LOCAL
AND TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS ENABLING
NEW SOLUTIONS WHERE THE PRIVATE
SECTOR IS NOT INVESTING CONNECT
ANCHOR INSTITUTIONS ALONG THE
PATH OF DEPLOYMENT AND IMPROVE
THE ADMINISTRATION OF THE CATS
OF PROGRAMS OR PROJECTS ARE
COMPLETED SOONER. I KNOW THAT
THE LEGISLATION IS FOR AN
EXTENSION OF THE CURRENT.
SURCHARGE WHICH IS AN EXTREMELY
SMALL AND OUR ON OUR PHONE
BILLS. SO WILL HELP YOU. CAN IN
THE LIVES IN. CAN THEIR FOR THE
BROAD. CONSORTIA FOR ADOPTION
ACTIVITIES WHICH ARE CRITICAL
AND KEEP THE FUN GOING UNTIL
OUR GOALS ARE MET. WE HAVE A
GREAT DEAL MORE MENTION
MOMENTUM TO MEET THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE CHALLENGE AND TO HELP
DRIVE ECONOMIC RECOVERY THIS
LEGISLATION. IS SUPPORTED BY A
BROAD NETWORK OF ORGANIZATIONS
STATEWIDE THEREFORE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY. I'D
LIKE TO STOP THEIR REALLY QUICK
JUST ESTABLISH QUORUM. AND
MADAM SECRETARY- PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. HERE THE OPERATOR
LINE NUMBERS NINETY. START
AGAIN SANTIAGO HERE PATTERSON.
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA CERVANTES
DAVIES. EDUARDO GARCIA. HOLDEN
LOW. QUICKSILVER RODRIGUEZ.
MATHIS CALIO. WE HAVE A QUORUM
THANK IN WITH A QUORUM BEFORE
WE MOVE FORWARDS ONE OUT MAKE
COUPLE ANNOUNCEMENTS THE I MISS
CARRILLO HAS BEEN APPOINTED TO
THE COMMITTEE TO FILL THE
VACANCY FOR TODAY'S HEARING
ONLY OFF LIKE ANOTHER MISTER
MATHIS WILL BE A SUBSTITUTE FOR
A MISSING OF ALLIGATORS FOR
TODAY'S MEETING ONLY AN ITEM
NINE AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE
MISTER PATTERSON'S BEEN PUT
OVER THE NEXT HEARING. AT WILL
CONTINUE NOW- WITH OPPOSITION
WITNESS MISTER PETER A BLOCKER
FOR THE CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION AND THEN SUPPORT
AMENDED POSITION ONE- MISA
MCINTYRE. SO WILL CONTINUE
THANK YOU. COULD I GET YOUR
MEMBERS BACLIFF CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION. THANK
YOU FOR PROVIDING THE
OPTIMISTIC VIEW TODAY. L.
DOCTOR DIRECTLY OPPOSES AT
FOURTEEN BECAUSE THE PROJECT
FUNDED BY THIS TAX WOULD HAVE
AN END DATE. YEAH AUTHORIZED BY
THIS BILL WOULD BE IMPOSED
JUDY. THERE'S NO REASON FOR
TAXPAYERS TO CONTINUE TO BEAR
THE BURDEN OF ATTACK. OBJECTS
WHICH THIS WILL. ACTUALLY
CALPERS RT PATIENT GET TAXES ON
THE PHONE SERVICE. ON AVERAGE
THE WIRELESS CUSTOMER IN THE
STATE IT MORE THAN 23% OF THE
TOTAL PHONE BILL AND HE'S TAXES
AND SURCHARGES FEDERAL STATE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHICH WOULD
ONE. WE ALSO QUESTION WHETHER
ADDITIONAL IS NECESSARY THIS.
NOW THE CALIFORNIA RECEIVE
FUNDS YOU MERICAN RESCUE PLAN
ACT. WHICH INCLUDES. YOUR
MARKET BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS. WE ARE CONCERNED THAT
ACCURATE RESULTS TAXPAYERS EACH
LICENSEE PROJECT. ADDITIONALLY
THE STATE MAY RECEIVE MOORE
FUNDING A TECHNICAL BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE OUR PRESIDENT
BIDEN STRUCTURE PACKAGE. IN
ADDITION TO THE SCENE OF YOUR
FUNDING PROVIDED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SHOULD PROJECTED TO
HAVE A RECORD TWENTY TWO
BILLION DOLLARS OR- WHICH IS
WHY THE GOVERNOR IS
MINISTRATIONS SPECIALIST STATED
THAT ADDITIONAL TAXES.
UNNECESSARY REPORTER. BECAUSE
PROPOSED THE AUTHOR WITH BUT
JUDY W. OUR THE COMPLETION OF
OUR- WHILE THE STATE IS A
SURPLUS INTERNAL HAVE BEEN
PROVIDED. BROAD INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS CAL TAX MOST
CERTAINLY- SPEAKING. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SUPPORT HIM IN A
POSITION- IS CAROLYN MCINTYRE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS
THAT CAROLYN MCINTYRE BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION-
WE SUPPORT IF AMENDED AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOURTEEN WHAT
HAPPENS ACTIVELY AND SHE THE
PROGRAM GOALS TO HELP DEPLOY
BROADBAND THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSEHOLDS THAT DO NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO INTERNET SERVICE.
HOWEVER ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS
ARE NEEDED TO ENSURE AT FOCUS
ON FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLES
ESSENTIAL TO ACCELERATING
BROADBAND DEPLOYMENT TO THOSE
THAT NEED IT. SPECIFICALLY CASF
INFRASTRUCTURE FANS SHOULD BE
USED TO FIND BROADBAND
DEPLOYMENT IN UNSERVED AREAS
THAT DO NOT HAVE SERVICE AT THE
SPEED LEVELS THAT THE FCC AND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAVE
THE NECESSARY FOR BROADBAND
SERVICE. PACTERA SURCHARGES OR
GOVERNMENT SUBSIDIES AND SHOULD
NOT BE USED TO OVER BUILD
EXISTING BROADBAND NETWORK THAT
OFFERS SERVICE SAID SPEEDS THAT
MEET OR EXCEED SPEED THRASH
HEALTH. PROBABLY SUPPORT THE
PROVISIONS OF AB FOURTEEN THAT
WOULD EXPAND THE PROGRAM. THE
CASF PROGRAM. WILL ALSO PUT
THIS PEACE WOULD SPECIFIC TO A-
THE CA PROGRAM. WHEN UNFETTERED
AUTHORITY TO FEND DECCAN
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS BY
INCLUDING AUTHORIZATION FOR
UNLIMITED INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS THAT INCLUDE NOW
I'M THIRD REQUIREMENT OR AT THE
GUARD RAIL THAT WOULD BE
APPLICABLE TO CASF GRANT. THE
BILL WITHOUT THE AUTHORIZED THE
IMPOSITION OF A TAX OR
SURCHARGE IN PERPETUITY TO
FENNESSY AT THAT PROGRAM HE
THINKS HE A SUBJECT THAT NO
ADDITIONAL TAX IS NEEDED GIVEN
THAT SIGNIFICANT FUNDING
RECENTLY PROVIDED TO THE STATE
BY THE FEDERAL AMERICAN RESCUE
PLAN IN THE ANTICIPATED
INCREASES IN STATE INCOME TAX
RECEIPTS. WE JOINED CAL TAX IN
URGING THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER THOSE SOURCES
OFFENDING. YEARS SEVENTH ST
RECTIFIED AND THE STATE FUNDS
TO SUPPORT THE ACT THAT PROGRAM
WILL NEGATE THE NEED FOR
POTENTIALLY BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
COLLECTED AT THEIR CHARGES FOR
TAX MONEY. BLACKPLATE WE ASK%
THAT THE BILL BE AMENDED TO
REQUIRE TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY AND DEFENSE THAT
REVIEW BY THE LEGISLATURE OF
HEALTH FUNDING FOR THE PROGRAM
IS SPENT OUTSPEND THE GENE AND
HOW MANY HOUSEHOLDS REMAIN AND
SERVED WITH CONSIDERATION OF
HOUSEHOLDS THAT ARE SLATED TO
BE SERVED THROUGH RECENT
FEDERAL BROADBAND GRANTS. FIFTY
TA HAS OFFERED AMENDMENTS FOR
THE OBVIOUS CONSIDERATION AND
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH HER TO ADDRESS. THESE
ISSUES THANK YOU. THANK YOU. IN
INTEREST OF MY- THE COMMITTEE'S
COMMENTS- LITTLE BIT MORE
QUICKLY- I'M GONNA BLEND
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WITNESSES
DON'T UPON COMMON PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD COULD NOT HOLD
UP- THE TIME IF THAT'S OKAY
WITH THE COMMITTEE. AND I WILL
REMIND THOSE WERE WITNESSING.
THE STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY
AND I HAVE TO BE FAIR TO EACH
AND EVERY PERSON WHO DOES THAT.
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
AND YOU'LL BE TAKEN AS YOU'RE
IN THE QUEUE- IF THE MODERATOR
WILL PROCEED FORWARD. WITH ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT- DUE TO EXPRESS
YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT ON AB
FOURTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. WE'LL
START WITH LINE EIGHTY EIGHTY
EIGHT ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PAUL
YODER- IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD TO SEE
RESIDENTS SAN FRANCISCO BUTTE
AND NAPA COUNTIES AND ALSO OUR
FIRM AS A SPORTING CONCEPT ON
THE BILL THE NEVADA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS THANK YOU.
THANKS WE HAVE LINE SEVEN SIX
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS IS THE ACTUAL PLAN GALLERY
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER IN SUPPORT.
LEVINE SEVENTY SEVEN SEVEN
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. JOINT
STERLING CHAIR OF THE WORLD
CAUCUS OF THE CDP IN SUPPORT.
LINE NINETY TWO NINE TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LINDA WAY WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT. NINETY
THREE NINE THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. RIGHT CENTER ON BEHALF OF
CHEN AND TRIPLE P. IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ONE NINETY FIVE NINE
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ERICA
HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. WELL I
NINETY SEVEN NINE SEVEN. HI TIM
GIL ACIDITY PRETENDED FOR
CAPITAL UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT. BY NINETY NINE NINE
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT
AFTERNOON JEFFREY NEIL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB FOURTEEN. LINE ONE HUNDRED
ONE ZERO ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON SYLVIA SO LEAST
SHOT ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SANTA MONICA AND ALSO ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION BUT THEN PUT QUITE
A BIT STYLE THANK YOU. FIND ONE
OH THREE ONE HUNDRED THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WHEN AFRICAN
DOLLARS ON BEHALF OF THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF GOVERNMENT SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE ONE OH FIVE ONE HUNDRED
FIVE WELL ACTUALLY WILL HAVE TO
MOVE ONLINE NINETY NINE ZERO.
RODRIGUEZ WILL BE UP EDUCATION
TRUST WEST IN SUPPORT. MY
NINETY SIX NINE SIX. PRODUCT
AVAILABLE. ON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BOARD ACTION FUND
AND CALIFORNIA ECONOMIC SUMMIT
IN SUPPORT. NINE ONE SEVEN ONE
HUNDRED SEVEN. FINAL SURVIVOR
WRITTEN ALL RIGHT ASHLEY WALKER
WITH COUNTY OF MODERATE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. LINE
ONE OH FOUR ONE HUNDRED FOUR.
DENNIS FOUR STAR LINCOLN SPACEX
M. CONCEPT IN SUPPORT WE
BELIEVE THAT SATELLITE NEEDS TO
BE SPECIFICALLY OUTLINED IN THE
BILL THANK YOU. LINE ONE OH SIX
ONE HUNDRED SIX. BUT BACK IN
BALANCE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. NINE ONE
ONE TO ONE HUNDRED TWO. DANIEL
GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF TURN THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK WITH THE
SUPPORT IF AMENDED POSITION AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNICATIONS WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE WHICH HAD
NO OFFICIAL POSITION AT THIS
TIME THAT'S BEEN CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE OFFICE OFFICE
REGARDING SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION.
LINE EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JONATHAN
HOWARD ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMAN IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE
ONE ALL ONE ONE HUNDRED ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON THE SETTLED
STATUS WITH THE PARENT
INSTITUTE FOR QUALITY EDUCATION
OR TICKET IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. LINE NINETY EIGHT
NINE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES RICHARD POLANCO
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
EMERGING TECHNOLOGY FUNDING
SUPPORT AND ASK THAT. THE FIRST
RIGHT OF REFUSAL AND REFUSAL-
AS WE MOVE THE BILL PLEASE THAT
NAME ORGANIZATION POSITIONALLY
PLEASE. OUR FINAL LEARNING
QUEUE IS ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE
ONLY. WE'LL GIVE OUR GUESS WITH
YOU KNOW WITH THE CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NORTHERN
LINE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU I'D LIKE I'D LIKE TO
LOOK T THE CHAMBER FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION WITNESSES AND AGAIN
NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR WAITING
PATIENTLY AS WELL. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MIKE WEST
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU R. N. I'D LIKE
TO TURN IT OVER TO THE
MODERATOR FOR REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION PLEASE.
I'VE BEEN TOLD
WE HAVE KNOWN UNLESS I'M TOLD
DIFFERENTLY I'M GONNA CONTINUE
TO MOVE ON- ANY QUESTIONS OR
ANSWERS FROM COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. YES. THANK YOU AND I
DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY-
ARGUMENT HERE THAT THIS IS
PROBABLY ONE OF THE BIGGEST
ISSUES THIS YEAR- MAKING SURE
THAT WE'VE GOT- COVERAGE
THROUGH THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ESPECIALLY DEALING WITH THE
SCHOOLS AND WITH COVERT I DO I
pRIGHT NOW THERE'S UNSPECIFIED
AMOUNT OF ATTENTION TAX
INCREASE THAT THE P. YOU SEE-
COULD GO AHEAD WITH NOT TO
MENTION THAT I DO BELIEVE THAT
THEY COULD ALSO HAVE NO
EXPIRATION DATE ON THIS FOR ME
TO BE ABLE VOTE ON SOMETHING
LIKE THIS I REALLY NEED TO KNOW
THE NUMBERS ESPECIALLY- THE
FACT THAT RIGHT NOW. THERE'S
BEEN A HUGE DEBT WITH YOU TILL
IT IS PAID THROUGH CO THAT I
THINK WAS LIKE ONE BILLION
DOLLARS AND A LOT OF TIMES THIS
WILL HIT THE LOWER INCOME-
INCREASE INCREASE MORE DEBTS OF
YOU CAN HELP ME WITH THAT I'D
GREATLY APPRECIATE IT. CUSTOMER
COMMITTEE IS TO GO THROUGH THE
TEARS JUST TO I REALIZE. AN
AWKWARD SETTING. STUFF
ABSOLUTELY I UNDERSTAND CONCERN.
WE ARE WORKING WITH THE SENATE
AND SALAS I HAVE A IN MY BUILT
A- PERCENTAGE IN HER SHE HAS A
FLAT RATE SO WE'RE WORKING WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION WITH THE
SPEAKER AND THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE TO COME TO A LANDING
POINT IS AS WELL WITH THE SI SI
PC. AS YOU CAN IMAGINE A BILL
LIKE THIS HAS A LOT OF MOVING
PARTS AND THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE
TO MAKE SURE AND THEN AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THIS IS THAT
WE HAVE- WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THOSE THE P. PEOPLE THAT ARE
STILL ON LAND LINES THEY'RE
PLAYING THE BRUNT OF THIS. THE
THIRTIES EQUAL TO EVERYONE ELSE
IS SO WE HAVE THE HOPE THIS IS
TO DECREASE THAT AND AS WE KNOW
WHO ARE THE PEOPLE THAT
GENERALLY HAVE THE LAND LINES
ARE RURAL COMMUNITIES ARE
PEOPLE OF COLOR THAT STILL ON
THE LAND LINE I PEOPLE IN URBAN
AREAS STILL HAVE THAT AS WELL
SO OUR GOAL IS TO BRING THOSE
DOWN BECAUSE MANY PEOPLE ARE
GETTING RID OF THEIR LAN LINE.
SO WE DEPEND ON THE FUNDING
RIGHT NOW AND IF THAT GOES AWAY
THAT FUND THE KEEPS GOING DOWN
SO IT'S IMPORTANT TO CONTINUE
THIS FUN BECAUSE AS WE KNOW
TECHNOLOGY CHANGES ALL THE TIME
AND SO IT'S IMPORTANT FOR ME
AND I THINK ALL OF US HERE IS
THAT WE'VE SEEN THE SOMETIMES
WE STOP WE GET MOMENTUM AND WE
STOPPED. AND THEN WHAT WE DO WE
END UP COMING BACK AND ASKING
ASKING FOR A BIG TAX REFUND OR
WHATEVER SOI JUST WANT TO MAKE
CLEAR IS THAT WE KNOW WE'RE
GOING TO PUT THAT IN THERE AND
I WANT TO ASSURE YOU THAT WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS WEEK
BUT. WOULD BE ADDING AMENDMENTS
AS WELL. THANK YOU. LOW THANK
YOU VERY MUCH IF I COULD I
COULD TO THE CHERUB QUESTION
AND COMMENT- MAYBE FIRST- JUST
A COMMENT ON. TO SOMEONE
AGUIAR-CURRY IT JUST BROKE. MY
HEART TO HEAR YOU TALK IN YOUR
OPENING REMARKS ABOUT THE
SITUATION THAT EXIST. AS YOU
KNOW I WASBORN AND RAISED IN
CURRENTLY LIVE IN SILICON
VALLEY. AND I COULD NOT FATHOM.
COULD NOT FATHOM THE SAME TYPE
OF SCENARIOS AND SITUATIONS AND
JUST. THE DEVASTATION
ESPECIALLY IF WE'RE AS WE'RE SO
RELIANT ON TECHNOLOGY THAT
EXISTS AND FRANKLY THE
CONSTITUENTS THAT I WORK FOR
AND REPRESENT TAKE IT FOR
GRANTED. AND I JUST ONLY
IMAGINE- THE SUFFERING THAT
THAT EXIST AND- TO REAFFIRM THE
COMMITMENT NOT JUST. I DON'T
COME FROM A RURAL AREA BUT THE
ROOF FROM THE COMMITMENT AND
SUPPORT. MAKE KNOWLEDGE MENT OF
THE WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE OVER
THE PAST YEARS CLOSE TO DECADES
OF WORK IN THIS AREA. SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR CONTINUE TO
ADVOCATE FOR PEOPLE WHO DON'T
HAVE ACCESS BUT MY QUESTION IS.
WHAT DO WE NEED TO DO TO
ACTUALLY PUSH THIS THROUGH AND
I KNOW. THE CHAIRS ALSO BEEN
ACTIVE IN THIS SPACE TO IN A
CRUISE TO THE TO THE CHAIR. BUT
WHAT WHAT ELSE CAN WE DO TO
HELP MAKE SURE THAT WE GET THIS
ACROSS THE FINISH LINE. WITH
IMPORTANT PIECES FOR US IS TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
LEADERSHIP. AND THEY HELP US
PUT THIS OVER THE FINISH LINE-
WE'RE HAVING WORKING GROUP'S-
MISTER SPEAKER HAS BEEN NOTHING
BUT MORE UP IN SUPPORT OF THIS.
AS WELL AS MY COLLEAGUES. AND
YOU KNOW WE CAN GO OVER AND
OVER AND OVER WHAT WE NEED WHAT
WE NEED WE'VE DONE THIS FOR
THREE YEARS NOW. ALL WE DID WAS
SIXTY AB SIXTEEN SIXTY FIVE.
THE TIME IS RUNNING OUT FOR THE
FEE AND WE'RE STILL WORKING
WITH A CONSORTIUM. WE NEED TO
GET THIS ACROSS THE LINE IF YOU
KNOW IF YOU SEE OUR SUPPORT
PEOPLE SAYING WHY NOT. AND I
WILL- PUT EVERYTHING INTO THIS
THAT THIS IS GOING TO GET DONE
IT'S GOT TO BE URGENT. PEOPLE
ARE LOOKING FOR US TO MAKE THIS
MOVE. THE ECONOMY IS LOOKING
FORWARD OUR STUDENTS LOOK FOR
HEALTH CARE IS LOOKING FOR SO.
ANYWAY THAT YOU CAN HELP
WHETHER IT'S HEALTH CARE
TALKING ABOUT HEALTH CARE THE
IMPORTANCE OF HAVING
TELEHEALTH. AND TO HAVE THE
BROADBAND. INFRASTRUCTURE
ANYWAY WE CAN HELP AND MOVE OUR.%
GOVERNOR LONG I'M I KNOW THAT
THE HE'S MADE THIS IS THE- I
KNOW THE CURRENT. THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS MADE. A
PRIOR. M. US REMEMBER THE
GENTLEMAN A COMMENT HE SAID-
THAT THE BIDEN INFRASTRUCTURE
INITIATIVE WAS WHERE WE CAN GET
MORE MONEY. CALTEX CALTEX THE
NATIONAL AFFILIATES OPPOSE THE
BIDEN AND INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
THE CONCERT SO WE GOT TO MAKE
SURE WE GET EVERYBODY ON BOARD
I CAN'T BELIEVE WE HAVE TO HAVE
THESE DISCUSSIONS BECAUSE WE
KNOW THE IMPORTANCE OF INTERNET
MARKETING COMMUNITIES. NO IS AS
THEM AND AS I REPRESENT NETFLIX
IN THE STREAMING AND APPLE ALSO
MY DISTRICT AND THAT'S A LUXURY
WARES YOU JUST THE BASIC
FUNDAMENTALS TO LIVE- IS IT IS
NOT SOMETHING THAT CASH EVERY
DAY CALIFORNIANS HAVE SO- WITH
THE SUPPORT OF THE CHAIR I ALSO
WOULD MAKE A MOTION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR- PASSIONS
ISSUE THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. AMONG IN IS WELL LOOKS
WITH A SECOND. THE SECOND
MICHAEL TELESCOPES. YOUR FIRST
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR ON A
SUMMIT MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY HAS
BEEN WORKING TIRELESSLY ON THIS
INITIATIVE BUT NOT JUST SINCE
THE PANDEMIC WELL BEFORE AS AN
EDUCATOR I WANT TO SAY THAT.
SOME OF OUR FAMILIES WEREFACED
NOT ONLY WITH A PANDEMIC BUT
ALSO SOME OF OUR FAMILIES OUR
FRONTLINE WORKERS AND THEN THEY
WERE FACED WITH HOW DO WE
EDUCATE OUR OWN CHILDREN. IN
OUR HOME. SOMETIMES A VERY
DENSE HOUSING WHERE THERE THREE
TO FIVE PEOPLE TRYING TO ACCESS
SO EVEN IN AREAS WHERE THERE IS
BROADBAND WE STILL SAW THAT IT
WAS DIFFICULT SO THEN IMAGINE
YOURSELF NOW. LIVING IN A PLACE
WHERE CONNECTIVITY IS EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT IF AT ALL IF IT
EXISTS AT ALL. THIS BILL IS NOT
ONLY TIMELY BUT- WE ARE OUT OF
TIME IN THE SENSE THAT WE KNOW
THAT IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
EDUCATION BUT IT'S ALSO ABOUT
EMERGENCY SERVICES AS WAS JUST
NOTED. ON TELEHEALTH THE
PANDEMIC HAS BROUGHT A WAY
ABOUT IN LIFE THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE AFTER THE PANDEMIC SO
WE VERY WELL MAY CONTINUE TO
HAVE SENIORS ACCESS HEALTH
THROUGH- INTERNET WE MAY
CONTINUE TO HAVE- STUDENTS TO
CHOOSE AFTER. THIS EXPERIENCE
TO CONTINUE ONLINE SCHOOL- IN
OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL SO WE HAVE TO
HAVE THE BASICS IN PLACE WE
HAVE TO HAVE THE SYSTEM IN
PLACE. FOR THOSE CHOICES AND-
WE ALSO HAVE DISCOVERED THAT WE
HAVE AN ENTIRE REMOTE WORKING A
GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS WHO NOW
HAVE THE CHOICE IN ARE BEING
GIVEN THE CHOICE BECAUSE OF OUR-
A LARGE CORPORATIONS WHO HAVE
SAID WE CAN. IN FACT HAVE OUR
WORKERS WORKING FROM HOME WITH
THIS ALL RELIES ON A
SUSTAINABLE WELL FUNCTIONING-
BROADBAND THAT IS ACCESSIBLE
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO NOT ONLY DO I
SUPPORT THIS BUT I AM A JOINT
AUTHORS. AND A PROUD TO BE A
SECOND TODAY AND TO DO ANYTHING
I CAN HELP MOVE THIS FORWARD.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE THERE
ANY OTHER COMMENTS. OR
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- I WANT TO TALK TO THE
OTHER SIDE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR WORKING ON THIS OER LAST
YEAR'S NOT AND- THAT'S NOT AN
EASY LIFT BUT IT'S ONE THAT'S
INCREDIBLY. UNNECESSARY ALL OF
US KNOW THE BROADBAND
DISCONNECT IN A LOT OF
COMMUNITIES OKAY BUT WE DON'T
EXPERIENCE THEM AS MY
COLLEAGUE. ADAM CAMPBELL HAD
MENTIONED. YOUR ORDER DID A
PANDEMIC- MOST SOME OF US HAVE
DRIVEN BACK AND FORTH AND- IT'S
INCREDIBLE TO THINK THAT IN THE
CALIFORNIA IT IS COMPLETELY-
DIGITAL IN SOME WAYS AND CAN WE
TAKE FOR GRANTED MAYBE IN SOME
URBAN AREAS THAT WE HAVE
CONNECTIVITY BUT- I WILL TELL
YOU THE SIX HOUR DRIVE FIVE AND
A HALF HOUR DRIVE. YOU GET
CONNECTION MAYBE ONE HOUR OF
THAT ENTIRE TIME IN- AND I
SENATE FEEL SORRY FOR ME
BECAUSE I DRIVE DOWN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA BUT BUT BUT THE
ISSUE IS THAT IT. WHEN YOU
REALLY TAKE A LOOK AT
CALIFORNIA IT'S IN. THE IN THE
QUALITY WHEN IT COMES TO
CONNECTION. IS EXTRAORDINARY-
THAT IN SIX HOURS FIVE AND A
HALF HOURS AND IN FACT THAT
TAKEN A BUNCH OF PHONE CALLS ON
THIS ISSUE FOR AND AGAINST IT
CONTINUOUSLY DROP PEOPLE ALL
THE TIME IT'S ALMOST
FRUSTRATING UNDERSTAND HOW YOU
CAN LIVE IN THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY AND HAVE ENTIRE
COMMUNITIES HUGE BLOCKS OF
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT THE
INABILITY TO CONNECT. AND AND
SO THE AUTHOR HAS MADE A STRONG
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE TO WORK-
TO LEGISLATIVE PROCESS ON THIS
ISSUE. I KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF-QUESTIONS AND I'VE HAD A LOT OF
FOUR CALLS A LOT OF OFFICE
CALLS AND HAVING TRAINERS BUT-
HERE'S HERE'S WHAT'S AT STAKE.
NOT GETTING THIS DONE. LEAVE
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
PARTICULARLY RULE AREAS- PLACE
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY WHO WILL
NEVER HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY
CONNECT. AND THAT'S THAT'S
WHAT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO
MOVE THIS ALONG FOR. AND ENGAGE
IN THAT CONVERSATION L. IT WAS
HARLEQUIN EIGHTY SIXTY SIXTY
FIVE I WAS PUT ON THE TABLE IN
A DIFFERENT TIME A DIFFERENT
PLACE- BUT MR GARCIA AND OTHERS.
IT IS BEEN INCREDIBLE. AND I
SAID THIS FOR APARTHEID BUT BUT
BACK TO ME STILL BAFFLING. HOW
WE'RE STILL HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION ABOUT NOT HAVING.
KEEP A CERTAIN COMMUNITIES NOT
CONNECTED AT ALL AND EVEN IN
TELEHEALTH HAS BECOME MORE
IMPORTANT. THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
HAS BEEN EXACERBATED BY
COLUMBIA. THE STUDENTS OUR
COMMUNITY SAID NO WAY TO
CONNECT AND YOU JUST NEVER
REALLY IMAGINED. WHO WERE
STRUGGLING TO CONNECT STUDENTS
TO SCHOOL THEY'VE BEEN
STRUGGLING TO CONNECT. ANYTHING
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE
INTERNET SORT OF SPEAK AND SO
FOR THAT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO GET THIS OUT- AND THE
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION- TO
THEM SO THAT THE RIGHT BOUNCE
IT IS- IT IS. IS DELIVERED TO
THE GOVERNOR'S DESK AND IT WE
FINALLY START TO MAKE THAT
IMPACT OF CONNECTING ALL
COMMUNITIES ADDRESS STATE
GOVERNMENT NOT I TYPICALLY
WOULD CLOSE IT NOW WE DID HAVE
A COLLEAGUE OF OURS WHO STEP IN
A LITTLE BIT LATE WERE UNDER
COBRA DIFFERENT- DIFFERENT THE
A. M. EVERYBODY'S RUNNING BACK
AND FORTH. ALLOW I KNOW BECAUSE
YOU WANT TO COMMENT ON THAT IN
JUST ONE ABLE TO GET HERE
BEFORE I PULLED MY MAKE UP. IF
IT TOOK YOU TO COMMITTEE THIS
WAS GOING TO CLOSE THE
STATEMENT I LOVE I LIKE TO
ALLOW LEAVES ONE MINUTE- TO THE
PREVIOUS ORDER THE BILL BUT WE
DO HAVE A COMMITMENT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON IT I THINK
IT'S HER ROLE AT THAT YOU TOOK
THIS UP AT A TIME THAT IT'S
MOST NEEDED. AND IT'S BUSINESS
IT'S AND IT'S BEEN MOST
DEMONSTRATED EVEN IF YOU TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT ONE IMAGE OF TWO
KIDS OUTSIDE. OF A TACO BELL-
TRYING TO CAN TO THE- AND
TRYING TO GET INTO. THOSE KIDS
ARE NOT GONNA GET THAT BY. THAT
SAME OPPORTUNITIES OTHER KIDS
AND HAVE NOT. IN THIS IS WHAT
THIS BILL REALLY SEEKING TO. I
TO ADDRESS. AGGRESSIVE ACTUALLY
BOOKED ONLY BECAUSE OF THOSE
OPPOSING COMMON IT WILL MOVE ON
A SET THANK YOU I WILL NOT-
STILL YOUR THUNDER MISTER CHAIR
BUT I WILL JUST SAY THAT- I
RECOGNIZE THAT THE BILL. IS NOT
IN ITS FINAL FORM. WE'VE HAD A
WORK GROUP- BACK HOME OF
STAKEHOLDERS THAT HAVE BEEN-
PROVIDING- FEEDBACK TO THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL AND- OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS ENGAGING. I JUST
WANTED TO READ SOME OF THE
POINTS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED-
AND AGAIN RECOGNIZING THAT IT'S
NOT IN ITS FINAL FORM AND SO WE
WANT TO MAINTAIN. PRIORITY FOR
THE TWENTY FIVE PRETTY UN
SERVED. DEFINITION I THINK THAT
WAS SOMETHING THAT IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT. TO FOLKS THE ABILITY
FOR TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS TO BE
TREATED EQUALLY AS AN
APPLICANT'S AS OTHER LOCAL
AGENCIES AS WELL OF LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES IS BEEN.
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AS WELL TO
THE TRIBAL AND NON TRIBAL.
MEMBERS OF THIS WORK GROUP BACK
HOME AND ABILITY. FOR
INTERCONNECTION OF UNSERVED
HOUSEHOLDS AND ANCHORS
ADDITIONS ALONG THE PATH OF
DEPLOYMENT INCLUDING THE
POSSIBILITY. OF MOBILE HOME
PARKS AND AGRICULTURAL HOUSING
ALSO A POINT THAT HAS BEEN
RAISED. PRIVATIZING PROJECTS TO
MAXIMIZE FEDERAL OR LOCAL FUNDS
CLEARLY IT HAS TO BE A PRIORITY
AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE- ALSO
DISCUSSING ANOTHER MEASURE.
AFTER AFTER THIS BILL WITH OUR
COLLEAGUE AL MURATSUCHI-
PRIORITIZE PROJECTS ALLOW OPEN
SOURCE OF THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE-
I THINK IT'S BEEN A TOPIC OF
CONVERSATION- TO TRY TO.
MAXIMIZE OPPORTUNITIES OF THE
DIG ONCE I HAVE. A CONCEPT. TO
REFORM THE CURRENT WAY PROJECTS
ARE PRIORITIZED IN THE BILL IN
ORDER TO HELP SIMPLIFY THE
ULTIMATE. ADMINISTRATION OF
THIS PROGRAM WILL MAINTAINING
PRIORITY OF UNSERVED
COMMUNITIES I THINK THAT IS THE
SPIRIT. OF THE BILL AND JUST
THOUGHT IT WOULD REINFORCE
THAT- IN THE WORKGROUP I
BELIEVE THAT THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE INSTRUCTING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO CONSULT WITH
REGIONAL CONSORTIA ABOUT
PLANNING. APPLICATION
IMPLEMENTATION SEEMS TO. MAYBE
BE SELECTIVE OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS VERSUS. OTHER
APPLICANTS- THERE SO THERE'S A
TO POUND THAT I KNOW THAT THE-
THAT IS SOMETHING BEEN-
IMPORTANT TO OUR LOW. IN THE
FINAL POINT. TO MAKE DELIVER OF
THE WRITER FOR REFUSAL I
BELIEVE IS SOMETHING THAT. HAS
CAUSED A LOT OF DELAYS. WHEN IT
COMES TO PC PROCESSING OF.
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED SERVICES
FUND CLEARLY THE ISSUE OF THE-
I. P. EXTENSION HOW LONG IT
GOES FOR- WILL BE FUNDAMENTALLY
IMPORTANT AND LONG TERM AND-
JUST WANTED TO NOTE THOSE
POINTS- THAT CAME FROM THE
WORKING GROUP BACK HOME. AND
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE THOSE COMMENTS THANK YOU
AGAIN AND I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY. THANK YOU. SURE
AND- I BELIEVE YOU DELIVER YOUR
CLOSING COMMENTS OF THE LIKE TO
NOW. WELL FIRST OF ALL I WOULD
LIKE TO THINK ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GARCIA AS WELL AS AND SANTIAGO
WE'VE WORKED ON THIS TOGETHER
FOR QUITE SOME TIME. WE'VE
GIVEN OUR HEART AND SOUL TO
THIS WE BELIEVE IN THEIR
CONSTITUENTS BUT WE BELIEVE IN
ALL CALIFORNIANS SHOULD BE OUT
EQUAL ACCESS TO THE INTERNET. I
DO WANT TO CLARIFY A COUPLE
THINGS THAT THE OPPOSITION
BROUGHT UP WITH QUICK LIKE IF
YOU DON'T MIND. I WOULD REMIND
YOU THIS IS NOT A TAX. MEMBERS
THIS IS THE FEE THE ESTIMATES
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
SEVEN BILLION JUST FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS FOR
CONNECTIVITY. AT THE CURRENT
RATE THE SURCHARGE WOULD TAKE
OVER A HUNDRED YEARS TO FIND
UNSERVED HOUSEHOLDS IN
CALIFORNIA SO YOU EITHER
SUPPORT PROVIDING THE FUNDING
TO MEET THE NEED FOR YOUR
CONSTITUENTS OR YOU DON'T BUT
PLEASE LET'S NOT GLOSS OVER
THAT REALITY. I IN RESPONSE TO
THE C. CTAS AMENDMENTS WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY GOING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH A CAROLINE AND HER
GROUP WE APPRECIATE SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT SHE HAD WE'RE GOING
TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS THAT
SHE'S BROUGHT UP. AND I HAVE
COMMITTED TO OUR MANY TIMES
BEFORE THAT I WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH HER AS WELL AS OTHERS
THAT COME TO THE TABLE. AND I
ALSO WANT TO SAY IS THAT I'M
HAPPY TO WORK WITH ANYONE THAT
HAS ANY CONCERNS ABOUT THIS
BILL- BUT IT. INFRASTRUCTURE
COSTS. IS JUST EXPENSIVE. AND
THEIR CONTENT ALL OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS. DIRECTLY BENEFIT-
PEOPLE DON'T OPPOSE FEES THEY
CAN SEE THE BENEFITS WHEN THEY
SEE THE BENEFIT THEY HAVE
CONNECTIVITY. HE'S REALLY DON'T
COME TO THE SURFACE LIKE YOU
THINK. WITHOUT MINISTERS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MR SANTIAGO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO I WANT
TO THANK YOU I WANT TO THANK
YOU COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH
US. AND MISTER SPEAKER AND I
ASK YOU FOR BEST FOR YOUR
ARRIVAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE
HAVE THE FIRST ONE IS STILL
AFFECTED BY MISS- CORK SILVA-
MASSACRED PLEASE COMPLAIN THIS
BILL DOES ENJOY A DO PASSED THE
COMMITTEE ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT-
MEDICAID PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB FOURTEEN MOTIONS DUPONT'S TO
COMMITTEE ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
SANTIAGO HI SANTIAGO ON
PATTERSON. BOERNER HORVATH
BONTA CERVANTES SEVEN TO SIGN
DAVIS. DAVIS NOT VOTING EDUARDO
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA I HOLDEN.
LOW LOW ONLINE COOK SILVA-
SILVA I RODRIGUEZ MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING CARILLO.
CAREER HIGH. MEASURES ON CALL.
THE IMAGES ON CALL THANK YOU
OKAY. WE GO TO THE- I'M TAKING
UP TO REAL QUICK WE HAD A AB
SIX SIX SIX PRESENTED IN
SUBCOMMITTEE- THAT WOULD. THE
FIRST WE HAVE A SECOND- FIRST
NAME IS NOT THE SECOND BY MR
LOW. I REPEAT THE NAME NOT TO
BE ANOYING BUT BECAUSE THE
SECRETARY COULD NOT SEE THEM
UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE
CASES. SO YOU MAY HEAR ME
REPEAT YOUR NAMES- WILL FIRST
AND A SECOND- MATTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I DON'T
NUMBER THREE AB SIX SIX ZERO.
SANTIAGO HI SANTIAGO I
PATTERSON BOERNER HORVATH BONTA
CERVANTES CERVANTES I DAVIS
DAVIS I EDUARDO GARCIA. EDUARDO
GARCIA HI HOLDEN LOW LOW I COOK
SILVA. COOKS SILVA AYE
RODRIGUEZ MATHIS. MATHIS I GOT
THE YOU COULD BE ONLINE. THANK
YOU AND THEN I'D LIKE TO ZERO
MEASURES OUT. EIGHT ZERO
MENDOZA I WOULD LIKE HAVE A
MOTION THE SECOND TO ADOPT THE
COMMITTEE RULES. WE HAVE A
MISTER MATHESON ARE RECOGNIZED
THIS CREATES A SECOND SORRY
MICHAEL SILVA. AND MANTECA
TERRY PLEASE CALL ROLE.
SANTIAGO HI SANTIAGO I'D
PATTERSON. BOERNER HORVATH
BONTA CERVANTES SAVANT TO SIGN
DAVIS DAVIS SIGN EDUARDO GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA HI HOLDEN LOW.
LOW I'D COOK SILVA KOK SILVA
AYE RODRIGUEZ. MATHIS MATHIS
ARCADIO CAREER I. COMMITTEE
RULES ADOPTED. THANK YOU MOVE A
QUICKLY LONG OVER AB ELEVEN
HUNDRED- MISS AGUIAR-CURRY THIS
IS- COMMUNICATIONS SERVICE
EMERGENCY DISASTERS REPORT
TAKEN FROM WE HAVE A FIRST BY
MR LOW. MEMBERS THANK YOU AGAIN
I'M HERE TODAY TO PRESENT AB
ELEVEN HUNDRED WHICH REQUIRES
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. TO COLLECT
INFORMATION ON
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICE
PROVIDERS EFFORTS TO REPAIR AND
REPLACE NETWORK INFRASTRUCTURE
AFTER MERGING SEIZE ORDERS
DISASTERS. YOU KNOW IN MY WITH
MY DISTRICT WE HAD WILDFIRES IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND
EIGHTEEN IT CAUSED MASSIVE
DEVASTATION FROM PROPERTY LOSS
TO TELECOMMUNICATION NETWORK
DAMAGE. MANY PEOPLE REPORTED
THEIR MOBILE PHONES WENT DARK
AND INTERNET SERVICE WENT OUT
THE FILLED TOWERS WERE DAMAGED
AN UNDERGROUND FIBER LINES
BURNED. IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AN ONLINE SURVEY
FOUND THAT 64% OF RESPONDENTS
IN CINEMA COUNTY AS WELL FIRE
AFFECTED AREAS LOS LANDLINE
PHONE SERVICE. JUST LAST YEAR
THE TWENTY TWENTY LOSS FIRE
REPORTEDLY DAMAGED
TELECOMMUNICATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE CAUSING
DISRUPTIONS IN PHONE SERVICE IN
THE AFFECTED AREA. STATE YOU
SEE HAVE FOCUSED HEAVILY ON THE
UTILITIES RESPONSE TO THE
MASSIVE DESTRUCTION. EVEN TODAY
LITTLE IS KNOWN ABOUT THE FULL
IMPACT OF THESE NATURAL
DISASTERS HAVE HAD ON
TELECOMMUNICATION NETWORKS AND
HOW TELECOMMUNICATIONS
COMPANIES HAVE RESPONDED.
CONCRETE RECOVERY PLANS ARE NOT
SHARED WITH THE P. YOU SEE ARE
THE LEGISLATURE. WHOSE JOB IT
IS TO OVERSEE THESE COMPANIES
AND REPRESENT THE PUBLIC'S
INTEREST WE NEED THIS
INFORMATION TO MAKE SURE
GOVERNMENT. A GOVERNMENT ARE
HELPING TO REPAIR EFFORTS AND
NOT IMPEDING THE RESTORATION.
AB ELEVEN HUNDRED REQUIRES THE
P. YOU SEE TO COLLECT
INFORMATION ON
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICE
PROVIDERS EFFORTS TO REPAIR AND
REPLACEMENT WORK INFRASTRUCTURE
AFTER MURTY'S OR DISASTERS. AB
ELEVEN HUNDRED NEEDED TO ENSURE
THAT STATE REGULATORS AND
PUBLIC OFFICIALS AREN'T FORMED
A TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICE
FAILURES AND NETWORK NETWORK
DAMAGE AFTER A NATURAL
DISASTER. I WANT TO STRESS.
THAT THE BILL'S REQUIRED
REPORTING IS NOT REQUIRED TO BE
SUBMITTED DURING EMERGENCIES
THEMSELVES. WITHOUT INFORMATION
THEM THE METHOD OF TECHNOLOGY
TO REBUILD THERE'S NO WAY TO
ENSURE THE RESIDENTS HAVE THE
SAME OR IMPROVE ACCESS TO
RELIABLE NETWORK. FOR MOST
CALIFORNIANS RELIABLE VOICE
TELEPHONE SERVICES NECESSARY TO
REACH NINE ONE ONE. WITHOUT IT
THE ABILITY TO CONTACT
EMERGENCY SERVICES THIS LIMITED
OR NONEXISTENT. WITH E TO
TESTIFY- ON THE PHONE AND
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS R.
CHRISTINE MAY YOU STAFF
ATTORNEY FOR TURN AND FRANK-
SAY THE C. W. A. DISTRICT NOW.
THANK YOU. Q. GOOD AFTERNOON
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU TODAY ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE LEGISLATION- TURN
INTO SOMETHING THIS BILL AND WE
ARE VERY GRATEFUL FOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ACKNOWLEDGED THREE
CURRIES WORK ON BILL. BECAUSE
WE SEE A GAP IN KNOWLEDGE AND
INFORMATION ABOUT OUR STATE
COMMUNICATIONS NETWORK AND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WE BELIEVE
THIS BILL IS NARROWLY TAILORED
TO REQUIRE THE COMMISSION TO
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE TO
FILL THIS KNOWLEDGE GAP. THIS
BILL REALLY IS A KEY PART OF
THE PACKAGE OF LEGISLATION THAT
WE WERE JUST DISCUSSING WITH
EIGHTY FOURTEEN TO SUPPORT
EXTENDING ADVANCED SERVICES ALL
OF CALIFORNIA AND TO CLOSE THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE. HISTORICALLY
REGULATORS POLICYMAKERS.
KERRIER DETAILED AND SPECIFIC
IN. ABOUT THE STATE'S COMING.
INDUSTRY YOU ALL KNOW WORK
THINGS QUICKER AND HELPING WORK.
TO THE UP THE REST. AND SHIFT
THE MARKET AND TECHNOLOGY. IT'S
CLEAR THAT THE FEAST ON. THAT
THE NET BUT CHANGE BUT THE NEED
FOR THE TYPE OF KNOWLEDGE AND
FROM CAN TO CRITICAL. ECONOMIC
TO PUBLIC SPEECH AT AT FAIRNESS.
YES THE LETTER ENACTED. ARE
USING THEIR BASE. OF THE AUTHOR
DOES. THROUGH THE FORTUNATE
ABOUT PLEASE OVER THE PAST
YEARS BY. WHILE. OF
TECHNOLOGIES AND THE TYPES OF
EQUIPMENT THAT WILL BE
REPLACING THE OLD DAMAGED NOT
WORK TO BE CLEAR THIS BILL IS
NOT DESIGNED TO REQUIRE IN THIS
OR EVEN TORIES OF INDIVIDUAL
PIECES OF EQUIPMENT. USED IN
THE REBUILDING EFFORT AND IT IS
NOT AT THE OFFICE DATA REAL
TIME REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
INSTEAD WE WANT TO KNOW WHETHER
THE REBUILD IT JUST. MEANT THAT
THE EXACT TYPE OF EQUIPMENT
CURRENTLY THERE OR- A REBUILD
NEW FIBER NETWORK. YOU SOME
PART OF THE AIR OF THE EXTENT
SOME PARTS OF THE AREA BEING
GIVE DIFFERENT. MAYBE BACK
POWER IS BEING. MAYBE NOT.
CONSUMERS NEED TO KNOW WHAT TO
EXPECT IN THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS
ESPECIALLY VICTIMS OF NATURAL
DISASTERS TRYING. TO REBUILD
THEMSELVES. LOOKS ANCHOR
INSTITUTION REGULAR ALL NEYMAR
KNOWINGLY AROUND PROP WHICH IS
KIND OF THE TWO MEN MARK. OKAY
LET ME- COVERED SPECIFIC ABOUT
THE- FIRST TIME TO HIGHLIGHT
THE FACT THIS BILL IS DIFFERENT
BECAUSE IT DOES. A TECHNICIAN
TO RE ON OCT. TO BE. WE BELIEVE
THAT IS A CO PART OF THE BILL
TO ALLOW LOCAL. FROM THE LATE
TO GET TO BE MOVED OFF. ENJOY
THE- OTHER POP TO BE- VERY
IMPORTANT OF THE BILL. ALL.
MISSION I KNOW SOME CONCERN
ABOUT COMP. HELPED UP AND TURNS
UNDER OF BILL. NOT AT. IMPACT
KERN RULE AND- OBLIGATION.
ABOUT THE CARE YOU'RE BEING
ABLE TO PROTECT WHAT THEY- TO
BE. CONFIDENTIAL AND- AT NOT
AREN'T FOR THE- CAN BELIEVE
THAT THE BILL. SO YOU WANT TO
WORK CERTAINLY WITH THE ON THE
CARRIER FROM THAT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE. MR
ARE AND- JUST REMEMBER YOU OF.
A RECORD TIME LIMITS. TWO
MINUTES PER WITNESS THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS FOR
GARCIA I AM THE DISTRICT NINE
BIKES PRESIDENT FOR COULD.
WORKERS OF A- WE ARE CALL COSTA
A BABY HUNDRED. DISTURBING
COVERS CAL NEVADA HAWAII IN. WE
REPRESENT IN THE COMING VIEW
BUSINESS AS WELL AS A SPECTRUM
OF OTHER AND. WE ASK THAT YOU A
B. HOW TWO SHORT OUR COMMUNITY.
AND INTEREST. IS FULL AND
RESTORE FOLLOWING THAT THE TO
STAY OF EMERGENCY. C. W. A.
ALTHOUGH. WHO ARE STATE OUT TO
THE- THROUGHOUT. WHETHER BE-
URBAN OR- TO RESTORE SO AND WE
CHRIS INFRASTRUCTURE WHEN
THERE'S CAUSED BY A WIDE OF
EVENTS. OUR MEN ARE THE ONES
TRYING TO GET FAMILY BACK. AND
BACK CONNECTED. OUR GOAL ADD IT
AND BE ENSURE THAT EVERYONE.
EVERY PHONE IS UP AND RUN THE
SHOW TIME. IN THE MOST OF ME
POSSIBLE LONG SERVICE. FIFTEEN
TO OFTEN WORKERS AT HER FROM
CUTS THAT NOT ONLY WOULD DO
SERVICE THROUGHOUT THE BECAUSE
OF A MY SO. BUT THE SERVER IS
NOT GOING LOCAL LAW PERIODS
EVEN WHEN MANY THEM ABLE ARE
BACK ONLINE. THE CARD SAID
CLAIMED THAT THEY HAVE
SUFFICIENT POWER COMPACT. TO
KEEP NETWORKS OFF DURING
OUTAGES BUT ANY FELL PEOPLE
PICKED A CAN. THAT THE FACT
FIXES NOT GOING TO. FOR PICKED
BASIC CONNECT TO PROVIDE BACK
UP OR FULLY OR DRONES AND
MOBILE ON PROVIDE ONLY LIVE
PAPER CUT. MODERATE FOR BACK UP
AND CONNECTED. REPLACING OLD
COPPER WITH NICKEL COPPER
LEAVING THE NETWORK OUT THERE
AND UNDER TO BE TODAY'S THE
TOMORROW'S. FROM UNDER HIS
MULLIN WASHER THAT THE- OKAY AT
COMMUTER NETWORK SHOULD BE WE
WITH ROCK CABLE THAT CAUGHT. TO
MANY TIMES COMIC. INDUSTRY HAS
GROWN LOCAL TO STOP PLEDGES. WE
OUGHT TO THE PEOPLE TO. AND
ESPECIALLY TO OUR CHILDREN TO
LEARN THE LEFT OF THE PAST. AND
THE WILD IN STORE BUILDING TO
HOLD PROVIDERS TO. THANK YOU TO
THE PEOPLE THEY SERVE. THANK
YOU NOW WE'RE GOING TO BE ON. I
MEAN I WITH- OR A ROAST IS IN
THE GALLERY REACHED. THIS
MEASURE- PRIMARILY BECAUSE IT'S
UNNECESSARY REDUNDANT TO
EXISTING REQUIREMENTS FOR US TO
REPORT NETWORK OUTAGES AND
RESTORATION EFFORTS. SO THE
PROPONENTS KEEP DISCUSSING
ABOUT ISSUES FROM TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THE WORLD HAS CHANGED SINCE
THEN SIGNIFICANTLY. RT
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCES
APPROPRIATELY POINTED OUT SOME
OF THE RECENT CHANGES. IN
TWENTY NINETEEN THIS COMMITTEE
IN THE LEGISLATURE THE GOVERNOR
SIGNED SB SIX SEVENTY WHICH
REQUIRED- COMMUNICATION SERVICE
PROVIDERS. TO NOTIFIED CAL OH
YES ABOUT ANY KIND OF NETWORK
OUTAGES AND THE RESTORATION
EFFORTS AND WE HAD TO MAKE SURE
WE KEPT THAT REAL TIME
SITUATION. TO PROVIDE LOCAL.
ONE HUNDRED A LOCAL LOCAL-
PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES WITH THE
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE PUBLIC WAS SAFE.
SO IN ADDITION TO THAT THE-
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
JUST ON FEBRUARY EIGHTEENTH.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THIS YEAR-
ADOPTED THEIR NEW RESILIENCY
DECISION WHICH REQUIRES THAT
COMMUNICATION SERVICE
PROVIDERS. AND HIGH FIRE THREAT
REAS PROVIDE SEVENTY TWO HOURS
OF BACKUP POWER. WITHIN EIGHT
MONTHS OF THE DECISION SO VERY
SHORTLY HERE WE WERE GOING TO
HAVE BACK UP POWER AVAIL
OUTLETS LOCATIONS AND WITHIN
EIGHTEEN MONTHS HAVE THAT
AVAILABLE TO THE ENTIRE
NETWORK. WITHIN THAT HARPER
HIGH FIRE THREAT AREA. IN
ADDITION TO THAT THEY ALSO
REQUIRE THAT WE KEEP OUR
CUSTOMERS AWARE OF ANY OUTAGES.
THAT WE KEEP THE PUBLIC SAFETY
FOR THE LOCAL FOLKS AWARE OF
ANY ALLERGIES AND THEN ON TOP
OF THAT AS PART OF THE SIX
MONTHS- REQUIREMENT WE HAVE TO
PROVIDE A RESILIENCY PLAN. TO
THE PC ABOUT WHAT WE DO TO
RESTORE OUR NETWORKS SHOULD
THERE BE DAMAGE TO THAT TO
THOSE FACILITIES. SO WE REALLY
FIND THIS- UNNECESSARY IN
ADDITION. THE P. YOU SEE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS ALSO-
CAPABLE OF GETTING NETWORK
OUTAGE INFORMATION FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. THE NETWORK
OUTAGE REPORTING SYSTEM NORRIS
IS AVAILABLE TO THE STATE IF
THEY KEEP THAT INFORMATION
CONFIDENTIAL. AND RECENTLY THE
FCC DECIDED TO ALSO SHARE
DISASTER INFORMATION REPORTING
SYSTEM REPORTS THERE'S REPORTS.
THAT AS LONG AS IT KEPT
CONFIDENTIAL THAT TALK ABOUT
THE RESTORATION EFFORTS THAT WE
HAVE SO REALLY THIS THIS BILL
IS A DAY LATE AND A DOLLAR
SHORT SO- WE WOULD- ORIGINALLY
WE WOULD. URGE YOU TO VOTE NO
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NOW WE'RE
GONNA GO TO- ANY OPPOSITION OR
ANY SUPPORT WITNESSES- VIA
TELEPHONE AND AGAIN NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY.
YOU TO STATE YOUR POSITION ON
AB ONE HUNDRED ELEVEN HUNDRED
RATHER ONE ONE ZERO ZERO ME
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD AGAIN THAT'S
ONE FOLLOWED BY. ZERO THANK YOU
WE DO HAVE. ONE LINE IN CUBA
JUST A MOM.
CAN NOT HEARING
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO A- REMOTE. IT IS
A WANTED PERSON MR WE DO HAVE
ONE PERSON FROM THE PHONE I
APOLOGIZE A TECHNICAL DELAY
HERE. SO NOW THE QUESTION IS
NOW GONE THANK YOU MAY CONTINUE.
THANK YOU NOW WE'LL MOVE ON TO
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION. NOT
HEARING IF WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION WITNESSES IN THE
CHAMBER I DON'T SEE ANYBODY.
SOMEONE TO GO AHEAD AND MOVE WE
HAVE FIRST OFF FROM MR LOW.
THEY STILL REQUIRE A SECOND. I
WILL SECOND. AND ANY QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SEEING
NONE I'M GONNA MOVE ALONG AND
ASK THE AUTHOR TO CLOSE. SURELY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I SIMPLY
ASK YOUR FIVE VOTE- I JUST
WANNA REMEMBER WE HAVE HAD SOME
LEGISLATIVE HISTORY A COUPLE OF
BILLS OF MY COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD ATTEMPT TO GET
THROUGH VERY SIMILAR TO THIS
BILL. ON THE DIDN'T AND NOT
THAT THIS IS A REPORT THIS IS
REPORTS SO WE CAN GAIN
ADDITIONAL KNOWLEDGE IT'S NOT
ASKING TO HAVE IT DONE DURING
EMERGENCIES BUT AFTER. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER ABOUT.
THANK YOU THE FIRST THE SECOND
THIS BILL DOES ENJOY TO PASSED
THE COMMITTEE EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT. ONAGER PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. MOTIONS TO PASTA
COMMITTEE ON EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I
PATTERSON BOERNER HORVATH BONTA
CERVANTES SEVEN TO SIGN DAVIES
DAVIS NOW EDUARDO GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA HI HOLDEN LOW.
LOW I COOK SILVA. SIX OVERTIME
RODRIGUEZ. MATHIS. MATHIS NOT
VOTE IN CARILLO. HI. SIX SIX
ONE MECHANISM CALLED SIX ONE IS
ON CALL THANK YOU SEE THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THANK YOU
NUMBER MOVE A LITTLE BIT
UPWARDS WITH SOME ISSUES WITH
WITNESSES NEEDING TO MOVE ON
AND IT IS CUSTOMARY FOR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO GO TOWARDS
THE END ANYWAY SO MISTER MATHIS
TODAY WHICH IS WE'RE GONNA MOVE
YOU AND MOVE ON THE AB THIRTY
FOUR ON THIS OR MURATSUCHI-
BROADBAND FOR ALL ACTIVE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. SO I COULD HEAR.
WITH THE FIRST ONE IS A MATHIS.
A SECOND BY MR LOW. NOW YOU MAY
BE GIVEN. MEASUREMENT MAY
PROCEED YES PLEASE OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN- AND YOU'RE A STAFF
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL YOUR
WORK AS A JOINT AUTHOR OF THIS
MEASURE THAT- I WOULD LIKE TO
PROPOSE- ON BEHALF OF YOU AND-
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA- ALL JOINT
AUTHORS OF AB THIRTY FOR. THE
BROADBAND FOR ALL BOND ACT.
LACE A TEN BILLION DOLLAR
GENERAL OBLIGATION BOND MEASURE
ON THE NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
TWO BALLOT. WE NEED TO GO BIG
AND BOLD AND INVEST IN PUBLIC
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE TO
CLOSE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
STATEWIDE AND JUMP START THE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY. BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE PROVIDES TO
ROADS AND BRIDGES OF THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY. WE NEED TO
ENVISION PROVIDING AFFORDABLE
RELIABLE INTERNET FOR ALL LIKE
WE PROVIDE WATER AND
ELECTRICITY. AB THIRTY FOUR
WILL HELP PROVIDE HIGH SPEED
INTERNET ACCESS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO CLOSE
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE IN EDUCATION.
SUPPORT JOB CREATION AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SUPPORT AND PROMOTE
TELECOMMUTING TELEHEALTH AND
TELEMEDICINE AND EMERGENCY
RESPONSE AND PREPAREDNESS. BOND
FUNDS WILL PRIORITIZE ACCESS TO
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE IN
UNSERVED AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES AS WELL AS LOW
INCOME URBAN AND EXURBAN
COMMUNITIES. BUT BOND FUNDS
GOING TO CITIES COUNTIES SCHOOL
DISTRICTS UNIVERSITIES AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES STATE
EMERGENCY SERVICE PROVIDERS
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES IN JOINT POWER
AUTHORITIES TO PROVIDE THE
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE AND
SERVICE. HERE TODAY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY FOUR IS A
CO SPONSOR OF THIS MEASURE OUR
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND. AS
WELL AS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES. MONTEREY COUNTY
SUPERVISOR AND FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LUIS ALEJO.
THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA GO TO TWO
MAIN SUPPORT WITNESSES ALL
START OFF AND WE'RE
RECOMMENDING TWO MINUTES WELL
MR GARCIA HAD YOU SLATED TO
SPEAK AMOUNT ARE YOU NOT
SPEAKING ON. THE TABLE YEAH
OKAY- FOR WITH THE MISTER A
LITTLE. THANK YOU ARMCHAIR
SANTIAGO AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THIS IS MONTEREY COUNTY
SUPERVISOR LUIS ALEJO AND I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT AT AN EXECUTIVE
BOARD MEMBER THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES.
AT ELEVEN O'CLOCK AT THE
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES AS WELL AS
OUR BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. AND
IT'S GOOD TO BE HERE WITH MY
FORMER OLLEAGUE AGAIN I LIVE
BY PHONE. MEMBERS ADDRESS THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE CALIFORNIA'S THE
MORAL IMPERATIVE. AND A MAJOR
CIVIL RIGHTS ISSUE OF OUR TIME.
THESE GLITTERY TECHNOLOGICAL
DISPARITY HAVE BONTA FAR TOO
LONG. AND WE MUST DO BETTER
RIGHT HERE THE TECHNOLOGY
CAPITAL OF THE WORLD. IT WAS
HEARTBREAKING TO SEE OUR
STUDENTS HUDDLED. AT THAT
RESTAURANT. LIKE THE PHOTO THE
TWO LITTLE GIRLS HERE ANY
SALINAS LAPTOP GET THAT WENT
VIRAL NATIONALLY. BECAUSE IT
WAS THE ONLY PLACE THEY COULD
ACT WITH THE INTERNET FOR THEIR
CLASSES. BUT THAT IMAGE
CAPTURES THE STRUGGLE TO SO
MANY OF OUR STUDENTS ACROSS OUR
STATE. AND OUR NATION AND LET'S
BE HONEST THE INTERNET IS NOT A
LUXURY ANYMORE JUST FOR THOSE
WHO CAN AFFORD IT. AT THE
NECESSITY OF EVERYDAY IFE AND
IT MUST BE VIEWED AS MINISTER
UTILITY JUST LIKE WATER
ELECTRICITY OR GAS. AND WE KNOW
THAT OUR STUDENTS WILL NEED
AFFORDABLE HIGH SPEED INTERNET
ACTED BEYOND THE PANDEMIC. BUT
SO WILL THE PARENT AND STILL
WILL SENIOR ACTIVE UNTIL HEALTH
AND OTHER SERVICES. IT IS
CRITICAL. FOR CALIFORNIANS OF
ALL AGES AND BACKGROUNDS. BUT
THE PROBLEM IS THE ONLY WAY.
FOR COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. RURAL
AREA ALONE NEIGHBORHOOD. IT
CALIFORNIA'S TRULY GIVE ATTACK
THAT THE- AND LOOKS LIKE A
BROADBAND. BOND NEXT YEAR. AND
WE ARE PROUD TO. THIS RIGHT NOW.
THAT COULD APPOINT THE BILLION
NEEDED TO COULD BE A THREAT.
DIGITAL CRISIS. AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE THE BEST
PARTNERS WE THINK LEADERS THE
FULL AND COURAGEOUS. ENDEAVOR
AS WE CAN MOVE PROJECT
EFFICIENTLY TO PERMITTING AND
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW. LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS MUST BE EMPOWERED
TO BE IN THE DRIVER'S SEAT WHEN
IT COMES TO PICKING THE DIGITAL
INEQUITIES. WE SHOULD BE HAVE
BEEN A VITAL PARTNER WITH
SCHOOL DISTRICTS CITY THE
COUNTY. FORMING GPAS ARE
SHARING PROJECT COST. EFFECTIVE
BONTA PROPOSED BEING. I WOULD
BE CLEAR. EVERY CALIFORNIA'S
THERE'S HAVE AFFORDABLE HIGH
SPEED INTERNET IN THEIR HOMES.
AND ITS LANDMARK BROADBAND FOR
ALL BOND WILL BE THE DRIVING
FORCE TO ENSURE THAT IT
HAPPENED TO CALIFORNIA. I WANT
TO THANK YOU ASSEMBLY NUMBERS
MARKETS YOU KNOW ARE THE CREA
AND JUST ON CALIFORNIA
TREMENDOUS LEADERSHIP. ON THIS.
IMPORTANT MEASURE FOR
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU- ONLY.
THANK YOU AND- I KNOW WE HEAR
SO. IN THE- SOME OF US THAT
AND- THEN HAND OVER. TO AND OF
PUBLIC AT- MISTER. THANK YOU
CARE SANTIAGO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU SOME ELEVEN
YEARS SIXTY FOUR YEAR
AUTHORSHIP OF THIS BILL IT'S AN
HONOR. TO BE ONE OF THE
SPONSORS OF AB THIRTY FOUR
BROADBAND FOR ALL. I'LL JUST
LAY OUT A FEW FACTS. IT AND-
HEY YOU ALL KNOW THEY'RE STILL
AS MANY AS ONE MILLION
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS WHO DO NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO HIGH SPEED
INTERNET IN OUR STATE- THIS
MEASURE WOULD PLACE- A BOND
MEASURE ON THE BALLOT. THAT
WOULD PROVIDE SOME TEN BILLION
DOLLARS THAT COULD BE USED TO
BUILD THE INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE
PLACES WHERE IT DOESN'T EXIST.
TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS
BROADBAND IN OUR STATE OF FOR
THIS. BILL TODAY IS SIMPLY A
VOTE TO GIVE THE VOTERS A
CHANCE TO DECIDE IF IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO THEY SHOULD PASS.
THIS BOND- COULD BE AVAILABLE
TO MUNICIPALITIES AND TWO
SCHOOLS AND OTHERS ARE TO
EXPAND BROADBAND IN AND I MIND
YOU WITH THAT TO SUPPORT. THE
NEEDS OF PUBLIC SAFETY OF FOLKS
WHO ARE OFTEN INCORRECT
RESPONDENTS WHO WERE OFTEN
WITHOUT BROADBAND THIS PANDEMIC
HAS UNCOVERED JUST THAT GAP IN
THE WITH OF THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
IN THIS STATE AND IN THIS
COUNTRY SO MANY STUDENTS WERE
NOT ABLE TO PARTICIPATE FULLY.
IN IN DISTANCE LEARNING MANY
CHILDREN AND THEIR FAMILIES
WERE UNABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN
TELEHEALTH. MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
HAVE THE TOOLS TO BE CONNECTED
DESPITE THE EFFORTS OF MY
OFFICE THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
AND SO MANY IMPLANTS. WE WORK
TOGETHER TO GET DONATIONS FOR
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF HOT
SPOTS IN COMPUTING DEVICES IT
JUST IS NOT ENOUGH WE NEED MORE
WHICH IS WHY WE HAVE AB THIRTY
FOUR IN FRONT OF US. MAYBE NO I
CAN BE IN THE TASK FORCE ON
CLOSING THE DIGITAL DIVIDE AND
WE USED IT TO SECURE A SECURE
COMMITMENTS FROM OUR INTERNET
SERVICE PROVIDERS AT LOW COST
BUT WE STILL NEED MORE AND ONCE
AGAIN I'M ASKING FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. TO GIVE OUR CITIES ARE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS OUR. COMMUNITY
THE OPPORTUNITY HAVE HIGH SPEED.
COULD PREPARE FOR THE OF. AND
TO KEEP ALL OF OUR COMMUNITY
I'VE- BROADBAND ALL I WAS. ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS ON A THIRTY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOW WE'RE
GONNA GO TO- OPPOSITION
WITNESSES OF WHICH WILL BE ONE-
IS MCINTYRE AND THE SUPPORT
AMENDED POSITION. WHICH WOULD
pBE ONE- THIS CORBIN. MISS
MCINTYRE YOUR BILLABLE.
ADMITTED CHAIRMAN A MEMBER
CAROLYN MCINTYRE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION.
AT THE CCPA MEMBERS SUPPORT THE
OPTIONS TO CALL ELEVEN SHARING
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE
ACCESS TO HIGH SPEED INTERNET
HOWEVER THE CTA OPPOSES AB
THIRTY FOUR UNLESS IT IS
AMENDED. TO AVOID THE USE OF
BOND FUNDS TO OVER BUILD
EXISTING BROADBAND NETWORKS
BUILT WITH PRIVATE INVESTMENT
THAT ARE FULLY CAPABLE OF
PROVIDING BROADBAND INTERNET
SERVICE. IN ADDITION THE BILL
FAILS TO INCLUDE GUARANTEE
THAT CALIFORNIANS UNSERVED
HOUSEHOLDS. WILL RECEIVE ANY
BROADBAND SERVICE. THE BILL
WITHOUT THE- A WAR OF GRAY TO
ELIGIBLE INTO TEACH FOR
PROJECTS THAT DEPLOY BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND BROADBAND
SERVICES BUT HAD NOOVERALL
REQUIREMENT THAT THE GRANT
FUNDED INFRASTRUCTURE IN
UNSERVED AREAS. SEVERAL
PROVISIONS WOULD CREATE A
CONFLICTING SCHEME OF
PREFERENCES DEMOCRATIC SIDE OF
25% OF BONDS AND- I SERVED OR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. BUT
THESE TERMS ARE NOT CLEARLY
DEFINED THE RESULT IS THAT THE
BILL WOULD CREATE THE POTENTIAL
FOR SIGNIFICANT USE OF BOB
SIGNS TO OVER BUILD EXISTING
BROADBAND NETWORKS BUILT WITH
PRIVATE INVESTMENT WITH NO
GUARANTEE THAT THE COMPLETELY
ANSWERED. REMOTE AREAS. OF
CALIFORNIA WILL BENEFIT. EIGHT
THIRTY FOUR WHATEVER VOTERS
APPROVE. TAKING ON A NEW TEN
BILLION DOLLAR LONG TERM DEBT
FOR BROADBAND WHEN CALIFORNIA
HAS NEWLY AVAILABLE FEDERAL
FUNDS FOR BROADBAND AND RECORD
STATE INCOME TAX RECEIPTS
CREATING A STATE BUDGET SURPLUS.
THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN
RECENTLY SIGNED BY PRESIDENT
BIDEN PROVIDES TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY BILLION TO STATE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND THIRTY BILLION FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT FOR USES THAT
INCLUDE INVESTMENT IN
BROADBAND. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE OUT THERE TO
INTERNET AD ADDRESS THESE
IMPORTANT ISSUES AND
SPECIFICALLY AS IT RELATES TO
DEFINING THE TARGET AT THE BILL
AND CARE TO POPULATION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF A
SUPPORTED AMENDED POSITION ON
MR CORBYN IF YOU'RE AVAILABLE.
THE FIREMAN THE RECOMMENDED TWO
MINUTE TIME. MISTER MODERATE
COULD YOU HELP US TO FIND OUT-
MISS CORBIN IS ON THE LINE. OR
FOR HER BENEFIT OPEN IF YOU ARE
ON THE PHONE PLEASE PRESS STAR
ZERO SO WE CAN OPEN YOUR LINE.
AND THEY CAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. OKAY LET
CORPORATE IF YOU AREN'T I
OPENED A PHONE LINE PLEASE
PRESS THE STAR AND THEN ZERO SO
WE CAN OPEN YOUR PHONE LINE.
HERE'S ALL YOU IN THE MEANTIME
JUST TO KEEP KEEP THIS MOVING
ALL ALL JUMP OVER TO ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION WITNESSES
THAT MAY BE IN THE CHAMBER. AND
AGAIN- NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION ONLY. MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS BIKE WEST ON BEHALF
OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY FOUR THANK
YOU THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION WITNESSES
IN THE REMOTE- TESTIMONY
STATION WHILE WE FIND THIS
CORDON. COMEDIAN BILL THIS MAIL
PUSH FOR TWO ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION WITNESSES THAT
WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO FIND ON THE
PHONE. STATE HER NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT ON AB THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
ABOUT FIVE COMMENCING Q. WILL
GO TO I. NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ERICA HOFFMAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASOCIATION VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT WATER DRIVE VOTE ON A.
B. THIRTY FOUR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RYAN SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE SEVEN FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LEVINE TO LINE ONE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
STERN MEMBERS SO THE IT'S A
LEASE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RIDE ONE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JOINT STERLING SHARE
CHAIR OF THE RURAL CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU RYAN ONE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
CALLING THE UTILITY REFORM
NETWORK IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT EIGHTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE EIGHT THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHEN JOHNSON
NUMBER CALIFORNIA MODESTO I AM
IN SUPPORT OF AB. ONE ONE ZERO
ZERO. I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
AND THAT'S BERMAN STILL HAS NOT
DIALED IT OVER THE PHONE- THE
STATE WILL MORE TIMES FOR
FAIRNESS OF TRYING TO GET
AROUND AND WE WERE CHIU SUPPOSE
SPEAK WOULD BE. SUPPORT OF AN
ANIMAL IF AMENDED POSITION-
MISS CORBIN. AMERICA BEGIN TO
WRAP THAT UP HE POPS AND LATER
DURING THIS MAYBE WOOD WE'LL
TRY TO GET ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. ON THIS
MATHIS. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
AB ONE SMALL CONCERNED WITH THE
BILL- AND I'M BEEN TALKING WITH
THE AUTHOR AND MISTER
MURATSUCHI I APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE DOING HERE ON- THE FIRST
SECTION DOWN ON ONE SEE WE HAVE
25% OF THE FUNDS TO PROJECTS
SERVING. UNDERSERVED OR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES- I'D
LIKE TO SEE THAT WITH THE
TWENTY FIVE FOR EACH OF THOSE
OF BECAUSE I KNOW OUR FOLKS IN
THE RURAL AREAS LACK THE
ADMINISTRATIVE ABILITIES AND
DON'T WANT TO SEE- FULL A IN
OUR SMALL RURAL AREAS THE JUST
SIMPLY DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY
TO COMPETE WITH OUR LARGER
DISADVANTAGED AREAS. OF RUNNING
INTO THAT BUT WITH WITH THAT
AND WITH GOOD FAITH. IN DOING
SO I WOULD LIKE TO- JOINT
AUTHOR THIS WITH YOU- TO ENSURE
WE DO MAKE THIS HAPPEN AND-
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU ON THIS MATTER. MISTER
CHAIRMAN MATT RESPOND OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF MISTER MATHIS I- REALLY
APPRECIATE- YOU KNOW YOU
EMPHASIZING THE FACT THAT THIS
SHOULD NOT BE A PARTISAN ISSUE-
THAT THAT WHETHER WERE A
DEMOCRAT A REPUBLICAN THAT THAT
WE ALL WANT. TO HAVE A STRONGER
BUS BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
THROUGHOUT IN ALL CORNERS AND
ALL PARTS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR- YOUR YOUR
SUGGESTION- I KNOW THAT WE-
YOU'RE NOT THE FIRST PERSON
THAT HAS RAISED THE ISSUE ABOUT
THE- RAISING OF THE- THE
MINIMUM GUARANTEE FOR. THE
UNSERVED AND THE- UNDERSERVED.
COMMUNITIES THAT THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES- BUT
I WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR- WE
WILL DEFINITELY- YOU KNOW.
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THAT AND
DISCUSS WHAT MAY BE THE- THE-
THE- THE RIGHT AND POINT UP
UPON WHICH SO YOU KNOW WE CAN
AGREE ON- BUT I WANT TO MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT. NUMBER ONE THE BILL
CURRENTLY DOES GIVE A CLEAR
PREFERENCE FOR THE UNSERVED-
THE COMMUNITIES AND NUMBER TWO
YOU KNOW WE WANT TO HAVE THAT
THAT FLOOR. RATHER THAN THE
CEILING IN TERMS OF MAKING SURE
THAT AT LEAST 25% GOES TO SERVE
THE UNSERVED AND THAT'S OUT OF
RECOGNITION. YOU KNOW-
PARTIALLY IN RESPONSE TO THE TO
THE CABLE. ASSOCIATION A
REPRESENTATIVE. THAT THAT EVEN
THE- FOR PROFIT INTERNET
SERVICE PROVIDERS HAVE
INDICATED TO. ME THAT IT
DOESN'T YOU KNOW THE MARKET
DOESN'T PENCIL OUT TO FOR THEM
TO EXTEND THE BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE TO THE RURAL
PARTS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND SO THAT'S WHY.
IT'S INCUMBENT ON US YOU KNOW
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
INVESTING IN THAT BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT WE ARE EXTENDING IT
TO YOUR DISTRICT. I MEAN THEY
GOT I TOLD SAID THE JOINT
AUTHORS AND THAT THE GOAL OF
THIS BILL IS TO GET. YOU KNOW
MORE THESE BROADBAND.
INFRASTRUCTURE BEING BUILT IN
DISTRICTS LIKE YEARS OR MR
SANTIAGO IS OR R. MR GARCIA'S
AND LASTS IN MY- COASTAL LOS
ANGELES DISTRICT- SO- I THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR THAT COMMENT AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU. ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU-
MISTER RODRIGUEZ PLEASE I THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MORE SECURE FOR
BRINGING UP THIS IMPORTANT BOND
MEASURE BEFORE THE BORDERS FOR
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE THIS
PANDEMIC HAS SHOWN US THE
IMPORTANCE OF CLOSING THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE THAT WE NOW
FACE. I BELIEVE NOW MORE THAN
EVER WE NEED AFFORDABLE
RELIABLE HIGH PERFORMANCE
BROADBAND FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
WELL I LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING THIS MEASURE HI HOPE
AS IT MOVES ALONG THE PROCESS
WE CAN REALLY FOCUS MORE ON THE
COMMITTEES ARE CURRENTLY
UNDERSERVED AND DISADVANTAGED
SO LOOK FOR THE SUPPORTING YOUR
MEASURE AND I LIKE TO ALSO BE
ADDED AS A COOPER IS WELL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
RODRIGUEZ. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. BEFORE I CAN BRING
YONDER CLOSING ONE SET UP ON.
PROUD TO HAVE A WORD WITH YOU
ON THIS AND THANK YOU FOR THAT
OPPORTUNITY. TO DO SO. I DON'T
TAKE A LONG TIME BUT THIS IS
SUCH AN IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT I
HAVE TO FAMILY SAID THAT IF
THERE'S- ONE THING THAT WE
FOUND IN COMMON ALL ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THIS PANDEMIC HIT.
IS HOW INTERCONNECTED WE WERE-
WHEN IT CAME TO THE ISSUE OF-
NOT HAVING ADEQUATE CONNECTION.
AND YOUR MAY SURPRISE FOLKS
DIDN'T URBAN AREA LIKE MYSELF
WE FOUND OURSELVES- WITH THIS
EXTREME DESPAIR- I DO NOT HAVE
ADEQUATE CONNECTION. EITHER
SPIEGEL FOR AFFORDABILITY- AND
WE FOUND OUT THAT THE
INSTITUTIONS THAT WE HAD OR OR
THE CONNECTIONS THAT WE HAD
SIMPLY JUST DIDN'T WORK OUT.
NOT WE KNOW ABOUT THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE WHEN IT CAME TO
EDUCATION. BUT IN THE SHADOWS-
THEY WERE THERE ARE MANY LAYERS
OF NEED THAT HAPPENED SOMETHING
SO BASIC. AND WE FOUND THIS
FIRST ALBUM CALLED IT HIT IT
TOOK A CRISIS. FOR THIS TO
BECOMES. SO MUCH MORE CRITICAL
AND IMPORTANT FOR US TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT. WE NOW HAVE BEEN
A LOT MORE IN COMMON WITH RURAL
AREAS WHEN IT COMES TO
TELEHEALTH. THE INABILITY
DURING A PANDEMIC. FOR LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
TAKE TO GET ON A BUS. FOR TWO
TO THREE HOURS TO VISIT A
DOCTOR PUT OURSELVES LITERALLY.
IN HARM'S WAY OR DEATHS WAY-
JUST WASN'T AVAILABLE TO LOTS
OF COMMUNITIES. AND WE THE
PANDEMIC FIRST HIT AND WE BEGAN
TO TALK TO CLINICS TO SHIFT.
THE GET CLINICS THE
AVAILABILITY TO CONNECT WITH
OUR CONSUMERS. WAS NOT MET ON
THE OTHER SIDE WITH FOLKS WHO
HAD NO CONNECTIVITY- THE- HUGE
EFFORT FROM SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
HAND OUT HOT SPOTS WELL WE
SHOULD HAVE HAD THE ABILITY TO
JUST CLICK A SWITCHING CONNECT.
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD BUT MILLIONS OF
STUDENTS ACROSS STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IT'LL I CAN'T SAY
ENOUGH OF HOW DEVASTATING. IT
WAS THE WAKE UP. DURING A
DURING A- COLBY CRISIS ONLY TO
FIND OUT. THAT GENERATIONS OF
CHILDREN WILL BE LEFT BEHIND
FAMILIES WILL BE LEFT BEHIND
THAT THE INTERNET ACCESS THAT
WE HAD AT HOME WAS INADEQUATE
FOR TWO TO THREE- COMPUTER
STREAMING AT THE SAME TIME THE
KIDS WERE NOT ABLE TO LEARN IT
WAS HEARTBREAKING TO SEE. IN A
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY AND THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD. KIDS SITTING OUTSIDE. OF
TACO BELL I BELIEVE THE WITH
THE WITH ALL THIS ALL OVER
NEIGHBORHOODS. WE SAW THAT THE
STARBUCKS WE THOUGHT OF THE
MCDONALD'S WE THOUGHT. PEOPLE
COULD AFFORD INTERNET IN WHEN
YOU HAVE TO MAKE A DECISION.
ABOUT THE AFFORDABILITY OF THE
CONNECTION OF INTERNET. OR THE
ABILITY TO PAY YOUR RENT PAY
YOUR BILLS. AND WE WOULD WE
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
RESPOND IN THE BIGGEST WAY
POSSIBLE IN THE- IN A IN A BOLD%
MANNER- SO I'M ENCOURAGED BY
THIS CONVERSATION MOVING
FORWARD. I'M DISAPPOINTED THAT
IT'S TAKEN US A PANDEMIC IN A
CRISIS TO. FINALLY RAISE IT UP.
BUT I'M GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP NONE THE LESS. BOB
THIS CONVERSATION AND GET YET
LAST YEAR WHEN IT WOULD YOU
KNOW WHAT MAYBE WASN'T MET WITH
OPEN ARMS ACROSS. ALL SPECTRUMS
WITH THIS YEAR- I THINK OF THE
YEAR TO DO IT BECAUSE- THERE IS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. WE'VE ALL
FELT IT I TOLD YOU THE STORY
AND YOU GUYS OF ALL HEARD I
CAN'T CALL ANYBODY BACK TO BE
CALLED ME WHILE I'M ON THE FLY
BECAUSE- I GOT ONE HOUR SIX
HOURS DRIVE TO CONNECT. AND
IT'S NOT EVEN A GREAT CAN
IMAGINE LIVING LIKE THAT FOR
THE REST OF MY LIFE AND SITE.
MY HEART GOES OUT TO ALL OF YOU
WHO ARE IN RURAL AREAS. OR
ALONG THE REGION'S THE
CALIFORNIA THAT I DRIVE TO.
DURING MY DRIVE HOME. SO WITH
THAT IN MIND. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO DO THIS. I TO GET
IT RIGHT TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION AND- LET LET THE
VOTERS HEARTS LANDING- WHERE
THE WHERE THEY WILL BECAUSE WE
KNOW IT HAD THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO BE WITH US. ON THIS SO- I
THANK YOU- TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM- TORRANCE AND MICHAEL IF
YOU COULD TELL OF VALLEY FOR
HELPING TO LEAD THIS IS A
PROJECT TO HELP ALONG THE WAY
AND- NOT HEADED BACK TO YOU FOR
YOUR CLOSING COMMENTS AND I
BELIEVE A- I GOT IT WRONG IT
WASN'T AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
AND YOU WERE GOING TO HELP
CLOSE ON POLITICS. JERRY BOB.
DAHLE BUT THERE'S BEEN TO WORK
WHAT ONE THIRTEEN YOU MIGHT.
ALL OF THE PREVIOUS CHAIR I
JUST WANTED TO THE REALLY
RECOGNIZED LEAD AUTHOR AND- HIS
TEAM. FOR TRULY WHAT HAS BEEN A
VERY OPEN AND COLLABORATIVE
EFFORT AMONG OUR OFFICES ARE TO
BRING THIS A VERY IMPORTANT
PIECE OF POLICY FORWARD. IT'S
EXCITING IT'S EXCITING TO SEE
THE LEVEL OF POTENTIAL
INVESTMENT THAT GOING TO
CALIFORNIA TO ADDRESSING THE
MANY ISSUES THAT WE'VE SEEN TO
DATE DURING THIS PANDEMIC BUT
THAT WE'VE KNOWN PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC- AS IT RELATES TO
CONNECTING UNDER SERVED
COMMUNITIES AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES NOT STATE. AND
THEIR DIVERSE NEEDS. WE THINK
TODAY OF THE STUDENTS WOULD
THINK TODAY OF THE TELEHEALTH
ASPECTS WE THINK TODAY OF THE
PANDEMIC IN THE NEED TO BE
CONNECTED FOR THE VACCINE AND
PRIOR TO THAT TO IDENTIFY. TEST
SITES RECORDED NINETEEN BUT YOU
KNOW PRIOR TO THOSE CHALLENGES
WE ALSO YOU KNOW I THINK OF.
UNDER LOOK THE IDEA HOW
IMPORTANT THIS IS TO THE GROWTH
OF CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES WITHOUT
INTERNET ARE NO. SMALL
BUSINESSES IN TODAY'S WORLD-
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS THAT
IN ORDER TO ATTRACT. LARGER
BUSINESSES TO PARTS OF THE
STATE THE NEED THE ECONOMIC
INVESTMENT YOU NEED THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND IT IS IT
JUST WATER SEWER ROADS TODAY
IT'S BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
AS WELL THEY THINK THAT'S WHY
THERE'S SUCH A STRONG EMPHASIS
ON. THE AREA OF UNSERVED RURAL
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA AND I JUST
WANT TO- CONFIRM AS A AS A-
THAT THEY AUTHORED THE LEAD
AUTHOR HAS SET THIS AS HE SAID
TODAY THE IDEA YEARS TO CONNECT
PLACES. DRAW CALIFORNIA NOT
LIKE THE ONES IN HIS DISTRICT
BUT THE ONES IN MANY OTHER
INDIVIDUALS DISTRICTS AND I AND
I APPRECIATE THE SELFISHNESS
THAT T. PRESENTS- WHEN PUSHING
THIS PUBLIC POLICY- FORWARD SO
FOR ME IT'S WITH GREAT HONOR
THAT WERE ABLE TO TURN OUT THAT
THIS BILL AND- THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT COULD REALLY
TRANSFORM- THE FUTURE OF. INDIA
AND I MENTIONED TO CELLO ARE
BUT THE FUTURE ARE DIFFERENT I
THINK WE'RE ABLE TO- REALLY GET
AHEAD OF THEM- BY MAKING SURE
THAT THE INFRASTRUCTURE IS IN
PLACE TO WITH THAT TAX PROFITS
BONTA THE BILL DICKENS JEFF
ALARM IS A FEW WORDS. IF THE
COMMITTEE WILL INDULGE ME ONLY
BECAUSE WE HAD MEMBERS COME IN
AND I'LL- IF YOU WOULD BE BRIEF
BECAUSE WERE A CLOSING COMMENT.
THE NO QUESTIONS WE ALREADY
WENT TO QUESTIONS SORRY NOT A
GREAT BUT- AGREEMENT IF YOU
WANT TO BE A BRIEF ONE ALLEN
TOLD YEAH. I JUST- AND I'M
SORRY THAT I CAME INTO
COMMITTEES AT THE SAME TIME. IF
THE AUTHOR COULD GO THROUGH.
YOUR BILL CREATES A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF FUNDING FOR MUNICIPAL
BROADBAND. AND ONE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT I HAVE
REPRESENTING SMALLER CITIES. IS
HOW ARE THEY GOING TO DO THAT
BROADBAND IS ACTUALLY VERY
EXPENSIVE TO DO. THAT HAS A
VERY HIGH OVERHEAD COSTS. IT'S
VERY EXPENSIVE TO MAINTAIN. THE
SECOND QUESTION A MAYBE IT WAS
ALREADY COVERED IT HAS TO DO
WITH. THE AMOUNT OF FEDERAL
DOLLARS COMING IN AND WHY THE
BOND IS NECESSARY NOW IF YOU'VE
ALREADY COVERED IT. THAT'S FINE
BUT IF YOU CAN ANSWER THAT
THANK YOU YOU CAN COVER THEM IN
YOUR CLOSING. ALL RIGHT WELL
THANK- LIMIT LET ME ADDRESS
THE- THE CONCERNS FOR THE OR
THE QUESTIONS REYES FIRST AND
THEN I'LL- A TRANSITION IN THE
CLOSING. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
YOUR QUESTIONS- THE- THE FIRST
QUESTION AS TO THE MUNICIPAL
BROADBAND- THERE ARE NUMEROUS
CITIES SCHOOL DISTRICTS-
THROUGHOUT STATE LIKE FOR
EXAMPLE- MR GARCIA HIS IMPERIAL
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION-
HAVE LAUNCHED A PUBLIC
BROADBAND NETWORK TO HELP CLOSE
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE IN HIS
DISTRICT IN IN MY DISTRICT
THERE IS A- JOINT POWERS JOINT
POWER AUTHORITY THAT WAS FORMED
BY A GROUP OF SMALL SUBURBAN
BELIEVE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HARBATH- THAT- THAT THAT
COMBINED THEIR THEIR- RESOURCES
TO- AND PROVIDE THAT- THAT-
CRITICAL MASS NECESSARY NOR
DOES SUPPORT. A MUNICIPAL
BROADBAND NETWORK- WEEK OURS IS
CALLED AT THE SOUTH BAY FIBER
NETWORK IT'S PROVIDING- A FIBRE
BROADBAND FIBRE BACKBONE- TO
CONNECT FIFTEEN CITIES THAT
WILL BE ABLE TO PROVIDE YOU
KNOW THE MORE RELIABLE
AFFORDABLE INTERNET SERVICES
FOR THEIR PUBLIC SERVICES FOR
THEIR CITIES FOR THEIR FAULT
THEIR FIRST RESPONDERS- YEAH.
THE HOPE IS TO BE ABLE TO
EXPAND IT- YOU KNOW THROUGH
THEIR THER PARKS TO PROVIDE
HOT SPOTS FOR- FOR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES TO BE ABLE TO
ACCESS THE INTERNET AND I SAID
SO THIS BOND IS SPECIFICALLY-
TALKS ABOUT. THE REQUIREMENTS
THEY THEY NEED TO- APPLICANTS
FOR THESE GRANTS FOR MUNICIPAL
BOND- MINUTES FOR BROADBAND
GRANTS AND NEED TO DEMONSTRATE
THAT THEY HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
BE ABLE TO- MAINTAIN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR AT LEAST
FIVE YEARS NO TO BE ABLE TO-
PROVIDE THE SERVICE- IF THEY-
IF YOU KNOW IF THEY WANT TO GO
BEYOND JUST LAYING THE
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE. AND
THIS- IT WOULD ALSO ALLOW FOR
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS I
WANT TO AND PLUS. OF SAYS THAT-
IN A WE EARLIER THAT THE SO SHE
SHOULD. EXPRESSING THE CONCERNS
BUT THIS THIS CAN CREATE YOU
KNOW NEW OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS TO
BE ABLE TO ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS ARE RAISED ABOUT THE
COSTS OF- PROVIDING SERVICE THE
COST OF MAINTENANCE. AND SAID
THAT- IS SPELLED OUT IN IN THIS
BILL ALSO IS GIVING PREFERENCE
TO GRANT APPLICANTS THAT COULD
DEMONSTRATE THAT CAN ADDRESS
THOSE THOSE ISSUES. LAST BUT
NOT LEAST YOUR YOUR- RAISING
THE POINT ABOUT FEDERAL FUNDS-
YOU KNOW I THINK OF. I HAD A
CHANCE TO TALK TO MY CONGRESS
CONGRESSMAN LAST WEEK-
CONGRESSMAN TED LIEU. AND AND
HE HE MADE IT CLEAR TO ME THAT
THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN-
DOLLARS OF DEBT THAT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WOULD BE IN A
STRONGER POSITION TO ACCESS
MORE FEDERAL DOLLARS. IF WE CAN
PROVIDE MATCHING STATE DOLLARS
WE'VE THAT WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
LEVERAGE MORE THE- THE FEDERAL
DOLLARS. BYE BYE BEING ABLE TO-
YOU KNOW BEING IN THE POSITION
TO BE ABLE TO OFFER MORE STATE
DOLLARS SO. THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO- LEVERAGE- AND
THE BILL AGAIN CLEARLY GIVES
PREFERENCE TO APPLICANTS. THAT
CAN DEMONSTRATE THAT THEY CAN
LEVERAGE- THE- THE STATE
BROADBAND FUNDS- WITH. LOCAL
FEDERAL PRIVATE AND ANY OTHER
DOLLARS THAT THEY CAN COMBINE
TO TWO OF A BILL THIS BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE SO- I THINK IN
AN ENCLOSING- YOU KNOW WE HAVE
A REAL OPPORTUNITY. TO TAKE A
CRISIS OF THIS PANDEMIC AND
TURN IT INTO AN OPPORTUNITY. TO
BE ABLE TO. YOU KNOW GO BIG AND
BOLD- AND INVESTING IN THE
PUBLIC BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE. TO BE ABLE TO
DRAW INTO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA MORE FEDERAL DOLLARS
TO BE ABLE TO PARTNER WITH-
WITH THE- THE PRIVATE INTERNET
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND OTHER
ACTORS IN IN THIS INDUSTRY- AND
SO- WITH THAT- MISTER CHAIRMAN.
HI I WANT TO THANK YOU AGAIN-
WE WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO.
GET TO THIS POINT WITHOUT YOUR
LEADERSHIP- WITHOUT YEAR-
STAFF- ADMINS YOU KNOW WHO I
KNOW RECENTLY LEFT THE
COMMITTEE HAS WORKED SO HARD ON
THIS BILL AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE. AS EFFORTS OF PEAS-
HAPPENS TO BE TUNING INTO THIS
BROADCAST AND I KNOW THAT- WE
ALL KNOW THAT MR GARCIA. HAS
BEEN- YOU KNOW WORKING FOR
YEARS ON ON ON. FOR AND EVEN
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC WITH HIS-
HIS EARLIER BILL- TO PROVIDE
INTERNET FOR ALL- SO YOU KNOW
WITH YOUR LEADERSHIP MR
CHAIRMAN WORK YOU'RE GOING TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE-
PRIORITIZING THE LOW INCOME
URBAN COMMUNITIES. WITH MR
GARCIA'S LEADERSHIP WE'RE GOING
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE GOING
TO BE PRIORITIZING THE RULE
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND SO WITH ALL
THAT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. AND I
BELIEVE WE ARE THE FIRST IN THE
SECOND- TESTAMENTUM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MOTION IS
DO PASTA COMMITTEE ON PRIVACY
AND CONSUMER PROTECTION.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI PATTERSON
BOERNER HORVATH. BONTA
CERVANTES. SEVEN TO SIGN DAVIES.
DAVID SIGN EDUARDO GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA I HOLDEN LOW.
LOW I COOK SILVA. RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ HIGH MATHIS. MATHIS I
COULD DEAL CARILLO I. EIGHT TWO
ZERO EMISSIONS OUT. EIGHT ZERO
MEASURES NOT CONGRADULATIONS. I
BELIEVE WE HAVE MISTRAL. KAREN.
MOVE ON TO MISTER WOULD AB
FORTY ONE. AND. YEAH BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE DEPLOYMENT. THIS
WILL IF YOU WILL THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS COMMITTEE
IS WELL AWARE OF THE MYRIAD OF
WAYS IN WHICH THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE HAS EXACERBATED THE
CHALLENGES OF THE PAST YEAR.
THE SOLUTIONS I PUT FORWARD IN
AB FORTY ONE OR NOT A SILVER
BULLET. BUT THEY ARE IMPORTANT
STEPS AS WE WORK TOGETHER TO
BRING CALIFORNIA'S DATA
INFRASTRUCTURE INTO THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY. SINCE TAKING
OFFICE COMMONSENSE EXPANSION OF
RURAL BROADBAND ACCESS HAS BEEN
A PRIORITY OF MINE. THE CONCEPT
OF DIG ONCE IS NOT A NEW POLICY
AREA FOR ME I'M BRINGING THIS
CONCEPT BEFORE YOU AGAIN.
BECAUSE UNFORTUNATELY SOME OF
OUR STATE AGENCIES DO NOT
RECOGNIZE THE URGENCY WITH
WHICH WE MUST ROLL OUT CRITICAL
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE. THE
FEDERAL HIGHWAY IN
ADMINISTRATION. NO TO TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF DIG ONCE
OPPORTUNITIES CUTS THE COST OF
BROADBAND DEPLOYMENT BY NINETY
PERCENT. WE CANNOT AFFORD TO
LET THESE OPPORTUNITIES GO BY.
PUT SIMPLY AS WE UPGRADE OUR
STATE ROADWAYS WE NEED TO
DETERMINE HOW NOT IF BROADBAND
IS A PART OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS. THEY WERE GOING
TO INVEST SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC
DOLLARS IN CRITICAL
IMPROVEMENTS TO BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE. WE NEED TO ASK
A LITTLE MORE OF OUR PARTNERS
IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR. THERE
ARE INSTANCES MY DISTRICT WHERE
BUSINESSES ARE INDIVIDUALS HAVE
PAID IN THE TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS TO BRING BROADBAND
SERVICE TO THEIR HOME OR
BUSINESS. WE HAD HOPED THAT
NARROW EXTENSIONS WOULD PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES TO CONNECT OTHERS
ALONG THE WAY OR MORE INTO MORE
INDIVIDUALS NEAR THE DESK THE
DESTINATION. BUT THAT'S NOT THE
CASE. COMMUNITIES ARE BEING
PASSED OVER NOT BECAUSE THEY
ARE NOT PROFITABLE BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT PROFITABLE ENOUGH.
JUST LIKE WE CAN UPGRADE OUR
STATE ROADWAYS WITHOUT
CONSIDERING DEMAND FOR DATA WE
CANNOT CONTINUE TO MISS
OPPORTUNITIES TO CONNECT
COMMUNITIES WHEN PRIVATELY
FUNDED PROJECTS BRING
INFRASTRUCTURE TO NEW AREAS.
ONE ENTITY PAIN STAGGERING SUMS
TO GET CONNECTED IS NOT WHAT
THE DEBT MARKET DICTATES IT'S
BROADBAND GERRYMANDERING. THE
EXISTING LINE EXTENSION PROGRAM
OFFERED TO THE C. P. U. C. IS
NOT ENOUGH AND I BELIEVE THAT
THERE ARE UNDER UTILIZED
MARKETS IN MY DISTRICT IN IN
THE STATE. I UNDERSTAND THERE
IS A SOME OPPOSITION FROM THE
CABLE INDUSTRY ON A ON THIS
ASPECT OF MY BILL. I HOPE THEY
RECOGNIZE THIS FRUSTRATION THAT
I'VE BEEN HEARING FROM MY
CONSTITUENTS. I THINK WE CAN
WORK TOGETHER TO SERVE MORE
CUSTOMERS WE NEED TO DO BETTER.
ON THE PHONE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS CALVIN STANDING WITH
THE COUNTY OF CINEMAS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT BOARD. I LOOK FOR
TO SOLUTION THAT SERIOUSLY
CONSIDERS EACH POTENTIAL
CUSTOMER FOR THIS VITAL
RESOURCE. EVERY TIME A SHOVEL
BREAKS GROUND. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. I THINK YOU
MISTER WOULD- WE HAVE TWO
WITNESSES- IN SUPPORT OF IS- MR
CELINE SENDING APOLOGIZES AND
IN OPPOSITION WOULD BE MR
OROZCO WHO WOULD BE A PERSON-
WE'RE RECOMMENDING TWO MINUTES.
AND MISTER SANDY YOU MAY BEGIN
IT'S SUPPORT. YOU CHAIR NUMBERS
NINE ALBUMS IN THE I'M
BROADBAND ANALYST BUT THE
CINEMA COUNTY ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT BOARD. I APPRECIATE
YOU TAKING THE TIME TO HEAR
ABOUT THE ISSUES EXPERIENCED
DELIVERING BROADBAND IN RURAL
AND URBAN COMMUNITIES.
BROADBAND CHALLENGES ARE
DIFFERENT IN ALL AREAS BUT IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT WE ARE
INCLUSIVE AND EQUITABLE CONNECT
ALL COMMUNITIES BUT CONTRIBUTE
INTERNAL ECONOMY. CALIFORNIA'S
DEMAND FOR INTERNET ACCESS
INCREASES EVERY DAY QUITE
SIMPLY CONSIDERED DATE WHERE
YOU LEAVE YOUR SMARTPHONE
SMARTPHONE AT HOME AND HOW THAT
AFFECTS YOUR DAILY ROUTINE.
CALIFORNIANS ARE DEPENDENT ON
BROADBAND IN ORDER TO
CONTRIBUTE TOWARDS THE ECONOMY
COLLECTIVELY AND IT IS ABOUT
THE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SECTORS
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE
EVERYONE HAS ACCESS. AB FORTY
ONE RECOGNIZES BUT TO GET
CALIFORNIA CONNECTED WE REQUIRE
BUY IN FROM BOTH THE PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SECTOR. BIG ONES
POLICIES ARE IMPORTANT TO BOTH
URBAN AND RURAL COMMUNITIES. WE
CANNOT SIT BACK AND EXPECT
BROADBAND TECHNOLOGY TO GET
INCLUDED IN THESE CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS. YOU
MUST BE PROACTIVE TO ENSURE
COORDINATION OF BROADBAND
INCLUSION BUT ALSO MAYBE
FORGOTTEN ALWAYS CRITICAL
RESOURCES AND TIME LIKE WE HAVE
SEEN HISTORICALLY. WE ALSO HOPE
THAT YOU WILL HEAR DR WORDS
APPEALS FOR INCREASED
TRANSPARENCY IN DISCLOSURES AND
SERVICE TERRITORIES. WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED MAJOR OBSTACLE TO
TRACK THE INVESTMENT IN TORY
KANEMI. INACCURATE DATA GAPS IN
TRANSPARENCY AND COORDINATION
WHICH ULTIMATELY RESULT IN
OUTCOMES THAT ARE MORE
EXPENSIVE. SONOMA COUNTY
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT BOARD IS
CURRENTLY WORKING ON IMPROVING
TRANSPARENCY BY CROWDSOURCING
GRANULAR HOUSEHOLD DATA
ILLUSTRATE WHAT ACTUAL
CONNECTIVITY LOOKS LIKE IN OUR
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT REGION. IN
ADDITION WE ARE EXPLORING THE
CREATION OF A PUBLICLY GOVERNED
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE ENTITY
TO INCREASE EFFECTIVE AND
EQUITABLE BROADBAND EXPANSION
REGIONALLY. BUT OUR REGION AND
MANY OTHERS REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT AND I BELIEVE APPROVING
AB FORTY ONE IS AN IMPORTANT
STEP TO SOLVE THE DIGITAL BOOK
DIVIDE TOGETHER. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. FIRST ONE UNDER TWO
MINUTES. I WANT TO GO AHEAD
AND- NOW INVITE. MISTER RUSSELL
IS IN PERSON THANK YOU. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BERNIE OROZCO
WITH A CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION-
CCPA WE ARE OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED SO THERE'S REALLY TWO
BILLS HERE- THE FIRST ONE IS
DEALING WITH CALTRANS AND-
INSTALLING CONDUIT IN THE RIGHT
AWAY WE ACTUALLY ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR OF THE YEARS.
SOME IN THE WOODS ATTEMPTS TO
HELP REDUCE BARRIERS TO
BROADBAND DEPLOYMENT- WITH THIS
PARTICULAR ONE WE WOULD JUST
SUGGEST SOME MINOR EDITS OR
SOME AMENDMENTS. THAT WOULD
MAKE THIS TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL
RIGHT NOW IT'S ONLY FOR FIBER
WE ALSO HAVE CO AXLE FACILITIES
THAT WE DEPLOY SO A TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL AMENDMENT WOULD BE A
GREAT AND ALSO. TO ENSURE THAT
IT'S EQUAL ACCESS FOR ALL
PROVIDERS WOULD BE THE FIRST-
REQUEST THAT WE WOULD HAVE THE
SECOND PORTION OF THE BILL
DEALS WITH DISCLOSING PRIVATE
CONTRACTUAL INFORMATION THAT IN
I. S. B. WOULD HAVE WITHIN
INDIVIDUAL PARTY- THAT IS
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION AND IT
IS PART OF THE HOMELAND
SECURITY CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. DEPLOYMENT
LIMITATIONS SO WE WOULD
RECOMMEND THAT THE FIRST
PORTION OF THE BILL BE
ELIMINATED BUT WE WOULD
STRONGLY SUGGEST THAT THE
AUTHOR CONSIDER MAKING
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSIONS-
LINE EXTENSION PROGRAM. WHICH I
WAS PART OF THE AB SIXTEEN
SIXTY FIVE FOR TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THAT WAS AUTHORIZED BY THIS
COMMITTEE. THE LEGISLATION IS
TO HELP THOSE PROPERTIES THAT
ARE JUST ADJACENT TO SERVICE
AREAS. AND THAT WE CAN GET THEM
SERVE- AMAZINGLY SINCE THAT WAS
ADOPTED BACK IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE PC HAS ONLY
AWARDED ONE GRANTS- AND THE
ONLY AWARD ONE GRANDPA BECAUSE
THEY LIMITED TO JUST LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. BUT JUST THIS
MORNING WE HEARD THAT THERE ARE
TWO NEW PENDING APPLICATIONS.
AND MISTER WOULD YOU WOULD BE
HAPPY TO LEARN THAT ONE OF
THOSE APPLICATION IS IN YOUR
DISTRICT IN THE CITY OF
OCCIDENTAL- THAT ONE HOUSEHOLD
IT WILL BE CONNECTED WITH
FIBER. AT FIFTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS IS ONE THAT IS PENDING
RIGHT NOW THE SECOND PROPOSAL
IS FOR FARMWORKER HOUSING. IN
SALINAS- THAT WOULD CONNECT-
SIXTY SIX HOUSEHOLDS ON A FARM
WORKER- PROPERTY. AT ROUGHLY
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
OF THE LIGHTEST ENGINE PROGRAMCAN WORK I THINK THE AUTHORED
MAY WANT TO CONSIDER. MAKES
CHANGES TO THE COMMISSION ON
THAT PROGRAM BUT RIGHT NOW WE
ARE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MR RECORDS. I
NEVER GONNA CONTINUE WITH- AND
I'LL ASK IF THERE'S ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION WITNESSES AND THE
CHAMBER AT THIS POINT I WOULD
ONLY ASK FOR NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION. I AM C. NON MOVE
OVER TO ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION WITNESSES. AND
THE REMOTES- STATION TESTIMONY
STATION. NONE THAT I'M AWARE OF
ANY ADDITIONAL ON SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE AGAIN MAIN ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION ONLY. Q. IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT ON AB
FORTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT FIVE
COMMENTS THINK YOU WILL GO TO
ONE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ZAKOPANE DURING CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ERICA HOFFMAN ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU ONE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JOINT STERLING CALIFORNIA-
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY
RURAL CAUCUS CHAIR IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU RIDE ONE TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS SPEAK CARLSON PERCY K.
A. WHERE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
DIRECTLY OPPOSED TO SECTION ONE
AS MR OROZCO SAID BUT WILLING
TO WORK ON SECTION TWO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RUN ONE TWENTY
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO WITH
FRONTIER COMMUNICATIONS OPPOSE
LESS AMENDED DEALING WITH
CONCERNS AROUND SECTION ONE
LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU ANY
QUESTIONS ARE FOR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MISTER MISTER LOW. AND
I WAS LOOKING FOR I FIGURED
ABOUT THE- THE ACRONYM H. T. H.
T. B. H. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER T. V. H. THE FIRST THE
SECOND. AND IF YOU WERE TO
CLOSE MISTER WHAT'S ONE LOOKS
ONE SAY THAT I THINK MR I CAN'T
SPEAK FOR THE OTHER BUT THE IS
VERY CLEAR ABOUT HIS COMMITMENT
TO CONTINUING TO WORK ON THIS
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT GETS RIGHT
BOTH WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS
INVOLVED SO WE THANK YOU FOR
THAT MISTER- WOULD. AND WOULD
ALLOW YOU CLOSING IF YOU WILL
THANK YOU- I AM INDEED ALWAYS%
OPEN WITH OPPOSITION
TO TRY TO CREATE THE BEST
POSSIBLE OUTCOME FOR A BILL-
WE'VE HEARD THE DISCLOSING OF
CONTRACTUAL INFORMATION AS A
HOMELAND SECURITY ISSUE FOR
YEARS- WHAT I REALLY WANT TO
HAPPEN HERE IS THAT IF SOMEBODY
AT THE FAR END OF THE ROAD.
PUTS IN A SPENDS MONEY WITH THE
CABLE COMMUNICATIONS FOLKS TO
PUT IN A BROADBAND NETWORK.
THAT EVERYBODY ALONG THE ROAD
GETS A SHOT AT BEING ABLE TO
ADD ON. NOW THE LINE EXTENSION
PROGRAM THAT WAS TALKED ABOUT
IT ISN'T WORKING. IT'S REALLY
NOT WORKING AND SO. THAT'S WHAT
I MEANT BY IT'S PROFITABLE BUT
NOT PROFITABLE ENOUGH SOMETIMES
IT'S LIKE CAN WE NOT AGREE THAT
IT MIGHT BE A SENSE THAT THAT
SOMEBODY DID EVERYBODY ALONG
THE ROAD TO GET ACCESS TO A
FIBER THAT'S ACTUALLY BEING RUN
OUT THERE FOR SOMEBODY- I THINK
IT IS AND I HOPE THAT THE I
HOPE THE INDUSTRY CAN WHO CAN
FIND THEIR WAY TO BE ABLE
SUPPORT OF WITHOUT. THE GUARDS
THE OTHER WE NEED INFORMATION
WE NEED TO BE WE NEED REAL
INFORMATION ABOUT WHERE THINGS
WERE BROADBAND IS BEING
DEPLOYED AND- WHERE IT STILL
NEEDS TO BE DEPLOYED AND WHERE
OUR OPPORTUNITIES ARE AND WE
DON'T GET THAT FROM THE
INDUSTRY RIGHT NOW IT'S ALL
GARDEN CLOAKED IN AND THAT'S
THAT'S UNFORTUNATE- YOU KNOW I
APPRECIATE THAT. THAT YOU KNOW
THERE'S A COUPLE OF INSTANCES
WHERE THE LINE EXTENSION
PROGRAM MAY BE WORKING BUT THIS
START IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
AND WE'VE GOT THREE NOW I
WOULDN'T EXACTLY CALL THAT A
PROFOUND SUCCESS FOR CONSUMERS
OUT THERE SO MY HOPE IS THAT
THE INDUSTRY WILL WORK WITH US-
THERE'S MONEY TO BE MADE OUT
THERE- THERE'S ALSO PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO BE SERVED AND I THINK
WE'RE MISSING THE BOAT BY NOT
OFFERING IT ALONG THE WAY.
WE'RE ALSO DEFINITELY NOT MEANT
MISSING THE BOAT WHEN WE DON'T
ALLOW THE DIG ONCE POLICY AND
WHEN OUR OWN STATE AGENCIES
CAN'T GET OUT OF THE WAY AND
HELP HELP US TO GET THAT DONE
SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR ABOUT. THANK YOU- AND
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS TO PASTA COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION SANTIAGO HI
SANTIAGO I PATTERSON.
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
I BONTA CERVANTES. DAVIES DAVID
SIGN EDUARDO GARCIA EDUARDO
GARCIA HI HOLDEN LOW. LOW I
COOK SILVA RODRIGUEZ. MATHIS
MATHIS NOT VOTING CARILLO. I.
SIX ZERO MEASURES ON CALL.
THANK YOU SHORT THANK YOU
MEMBERS. THANK YOU. MISTER
MATHIS ARE YOU PREPARED. THANK
YOU IF YOU'D LIKE TO BEGIN WITH.
AB. THIRTEEN FORTY NINE. YES
PLEASE. YEAH. AND YOU MAY BEGIN
WHEN YOU BAKER THIRTEEN FORTY
NINE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS- I WANT TO START WITH-
THINKING THE- COMMITTEE STAFF
IN THE CHAIRMAN FURTHER HELP-
WITH THE AMENDMENTS ON AB
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE- THIS IS
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED SERVICES
FUND BROADBAND ADOPTION
ACCOUNTS- VERY SIMPLY WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE AND I
UNDERSTAND. THERE'S A LOT OF
CONCERN WITH THE SEPARATION OF
CHURCH AND STATE ON THIS BILL
BUT THE FACT IS MEMBERS THAT
WHEN YOU LOOK AT OUR ROLE IN
OUR DISADVANTAGED AREAS IS
WE'VE HEARD FROM OTHER. AUTHORS
TODAY. THAT THESE AREAS ARE
OFTEN FORGOTTEN THIS ISN'T
ABOUT GIVEN A MEGA CHURCH OR
DIOCESE THE ABILITY TO TAKE
STATE FUNDING TO BOOST
SOMETHING HAT THEY ALREADY
HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO WHAT
THIS IS ABOUT IS WE HAVE THESE
AREAS THE SMALL POCKETS IN
CALIFORNIA. WE'RE THE ONLY
COMMUNITY CENTER THAT IS THERE.
IS VERY RELIGIOUS INSTITUTION
IT'S THAT SMALL COMMUNITY
CHURCH WHERE KIDS GO AFTER
SCHOOL TO DO THEIR HOMEWORK BUT
THEY DON'T HAVE INTERNET THEY
DON'T HAVE BROADBAND. SO IT'S
MAKING SURE THAT THOSE VERY
VERY SMALL FEW PLACES. CAN GET
THE ABILITY TO USE THESE FUNDS
SO THAT WITH THOSE COMMUNITIES
THOSE FORGOTTEN COMMUNITIES
ACROSS OUR STATE. CAN GET
ACCESS. WITH THAT I'M OPEN TO
ANY QUESTIONS FOR MANY MEMBERS
BUT I WANT TO JUST BE VERY
SPECIFIC THAT IT'S NOT ABOUT.
BIG MEGA CHURCHES GETTING
STATE. TAX DOLLARS THIS IS
ABOUT THESE TINY TINY LITTLE
COMMUNITY CENTERS. THEY JUST
HAPPEN TO BE CHURCHES. YOU
AGREED TO THE AMENDMENTS ACCESS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
COMEDIAN YET YES MISTER CHAIR I
DID OPEN WITH TAKING YOUR
AMENDMENTS AND THINKING I CAN'T
BE LIKE THAT. WE HAVE A FOR A
FIRST- MISTER GARCIA SECONDUS
TELLS- TRY OF MASCOTS THE
COMMUTER FOR SOME- WE HAVE A
MAIN SUPPORTERS- WE HAVE NO MAY
SUPPORTERS KNOW MAIN OPPOSITION
SOME OF SKIP THOSE AND THEN
MOVE ON TO ANY. ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT OPPOSITION THAT MAYBE
IN THE CHAMBERS NOT SEEING
ANYONE A CHAMBERS MOVE ON ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. IN THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE ARE
NONE THEIR FOR THIS- LEAVE IT
TO ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WHO MAY BE
ON THE PHONE. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT JOHN AB
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AGAIN TO COMMENT ON
EIGHTY THIRTEEN FORTY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
NO COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME. ANY QUESTION FROM OF
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. NOT SEEING
ANY IF YOU HAVE ANY. CLOSING
STATEMENTS. AGAIN MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WANT TO THANK
YOURSELF AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF ON THE HARD WORK FOR THE
AMENDMENTS ON THIS. AGAIN
MEMBERS THIS IS A VERY NARROWLY
WRITTEN TO HELP OR
DISADVANTAGED AREAS WHERE THEY
DON'T HAVE ANY OTHER PLACE TO
GO ANY OTHER TYPE OF A
COMMUNITY CENTER TO ENSURE THAT
OUR KIDS HAVE SOMEWHERE WHERE
THEY'RE ALREADY GOING. TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
INTERNET. WITHOUT ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU- NOW WE
HAVE A FIRST- WE'LL FIRST MR
GARCIA SECOND. MISTER ROBERTS-
MADAMS AND I REPEATING BECAUSE
I I'VE NOTICED I DON'T THINK WE
GOT THAT THE FIRST TIME MAN
CENTER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION ON AB THIRTEEN FORTY
NINE IS DUE PROCESS AMENDED TO
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
SANTIAGO HI SANTIAGO I
PATTERSON. PATTERSON I SPENT A
WHOLE THAT WON'T BURN A HOLE
THAT I BONTA. CERVANTES.
CERVANTES SIGH DAVIES DAVIS III
EDUARDO GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
HI HOLDEN LOW. LOW I WOKE SILVA.
COOK SILVA I RODRIGUEZ. MATHIS
MATHIS I COULD DO. NINE TWO
ZERO MEASURES OUT. THANK YOU.
TO MY NEXT BILL HERE AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX AND- I KNOW
WE'VE BEEN HERE. ALL AFTERNOON
NUMBER SO MAKE THIS SHORT- WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT WITH- BUT WHAT
I CONSIDER MY RIGHT OF FIRST
REFUSAL BILL IS WE'RE SIMPLY
GETTING INTO THE MECHANICS OF
WHAT'S GOING ON AT THE UC OR
WORKING WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS TO REALLY
KIND OF TAKE THAT MICROSCOPIC
SCALPEL APPROACH BE VERY
SURGICAL ABOUT WHAT WE NEED TO
DO TO SPEED UP THE PROCESS WHAT
WE NEED TO DO TO CUT RED TAPE
TO CUT GREEN TAPE TO GET THINGS
DONE- SO AS FUNDING COMES IN WE
CAN GET THESE PROJECTS DONE AND
IT'S NOT TAKING SEVEN TO TEN
YEARS TO BUILD A LINE. WITH
THAT MEMBERS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. WE DON'T HAVE ANY MAIN
OPPOSITION SUPPORT NO MAIN
OPPOSITION WITNESS ALL ASK IF
THERE'S ANY IN THE CHAMBER AND
SEEN ON ALL ASK IF THERE'S ANY
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION. THE
SALMON THAT THERE AREN'T ANY
OFF ASK IF THERE'S ANY ON THE
PHONE. A QUESTION THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO MAKE IT HAPPEN.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT ON EIGHTY FOURTEEN
TWENTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN
FOR COMMENT BUT HE'S WORKING
TWENTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. NOT
HEARING ANY I'LL ASK FOR A
BRIEF CLOSING STATEMENT FROM
THE ALTAR. ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU- MENFOLK WE
HAVE A FIRST OF SACRAMENTO
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HEY. THE LONG. WELL FIRST
SECOND. APPLE DEVELOPERS. HE
DIFFICULT THE MOTION IS THE
PASTA COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATION SANTIAGO. HI
SANTIAGO I PATTERSON. PARIS
PATTERSON I BUT OVER BONTA.
CERVANTES SEVEN TO SIGN DAVIES
DAVIS AYE EDUARDO GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA HI HOLDEN LOW.
LOW I COOK SILVA. COOKS SILVA
AYE RODRIGUEZ MATHIS HI MATHIS
ONTARIO. EIGHT TWO ZERO
MEASURES OUT. I HAVE A QUICK
URGENT THING THAT WE NEED TO DO
MEMBERS AND WE'RE GONNA OPEN
THE ROLE- ON SOME BILLS- THAT
WERE ON CALL SO- SO MEMBERS CAN
LEAVE DEBATE OVER THE ROLE OF
SOME OF THE- FIXED. THANK YOU.
NUMBER ONE AB FOURTEEN. AGILA
CURRY CURRENT VOTE IS. SIX
ZERO. PATTERSON PATTERSON-
BOERNER HORVATH. BONTA HOLDEN.
RODRIGUEZ. SIX ONE MEASURES
BACK ON CALL. I AM NUMBER TWO
AB ONE ONE ZERO ZERO AGILA
CURRY. PATTERSON PATTERSON-
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA. HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I. RODRIGUEZ. SEVEN TWO
MEASURES OUT. THE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB FORTY ONE MISTER WOULD.
PATTERSON PATTERSON NOW. BONTA
CERVANTES SEVEN TO SIGH. HOLDEN
HOLDEN I QUICKSILVER KOK SILVA
I RODRIGUEZ. NINE ONE MEASURES
OUT. DO YOU WANT ME TO GO BACK
FROM STOCKHOLM. WOULD YOU LIKE
ME TO PREVENT FROM STOPPING. ON
A. B. FOURTEEN. YEAH. ON THE AB
TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN- THIS PERSON.
SHARE MEMBERS UP. PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY SEVEN WHICH
PROPOSES A MODEST PROCEDURAL
IMPROVEMENT FOR THE SMALL RURAL
TELEPHONE COMPANIES. BOB THANK
YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT I
KNOW IN THE INTEREST OF TIME
I'D LIKE TO DEFER AS TO-
YOLANDA BENSON ON THE PHONE
WITH CAL COMFORT TO MINUTEST
MONEY. THANK YOU. HAS BEEN ON
THE PHONE UNIVERSITY. KAMALA
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON CARE
PONTIAC ON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY ON
EIGHTY TWELVE FIFTY. THE END OF
THE DAY AS REPORTED IN THE
ANALYSIS CHALCOLITHIC SPONSOR
OF THE BILL IN OUTLOOK
MENTIONED AND WE ARE IN THE
OFFICE STATE BUT- THAT HE WAS
GOING TO MAKE IT IS A MODEL
EFFORT. TO PROVIDE LEGISLATIVE
GUIDED TO THE COMMISSION THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION TO
MAKE A FORMAL RIGHT CASE PROFIT
PLATTSBURGH THEM. BY THE VERY
SMALL WORLD TELEPHONE COMPANY.
BECAUSE A FIVE SETTER OR FORTY.
PROCESS IS NO LONGER ALLOWED BY
THE COMMISSION OUR COMPANIES
MUST NOW FILE A FORMAL RATE
CASE APPLICATION EVERY FIVE
YEARS AT A COST USUALLY TWO TO
FOUR TIMES MORE EXPENSIVE. THAN
THE INFORMAL INVITE LETTER
PROCESS. THE BILL INCLUDES TWO
SMALL REFORMS INTENDED TO
ENCOURAGE COMMUNICATION AND
COOPERATION AMONG THE PARTY TO
THE RIGHT CASE THEY ARE. IN ONE
DAY OF NONBINDING MEDIATIONS
LED BY AN ALJ TRAINED IN
ALTERNATIVE DISPUTE RESOLUTION
AND WE WILL CONFIRM
REQUIREMENTS. PRIOR TO BRINGING
THE MOTION. WELL THE NOT LIMIT
COMMISSION DISK AND- WE DO
BELIEVE THAT A MORE EFFICIENT
CAR EFFECTIVE AND HIGH. RATE
OKAY BOTH THE COMMISSION AND
THE COMPANY. THE WORLD HEALTH
COMPANIES CRITICAL AND NEEDED
THE THEIR AREAS AND WITHOUT
FAMILY AFTER THE FORM RIGHT
CASE PROMPTED THE TWO. TIME NOW
WITH. ARE SIMPLY NOT
SUSTAINABLE FOR THE FALL CA.
THEREFORE WE ASK FOR YOUR I.
THE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I
DON'T SEE ANY OPPOSITION-
WITNESSES SO WILL GO
IMMEDIATELY TO THE CHAMBERS FOR
ANY FOR OR AGAINST WITNESSES.
ANY TO REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
I'M NOT AWARE OF ANY SUCH A
MOVE OVER QUICKLY TO THE-
TELEPHONE IF THERE'S ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OPPOSITION
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT AND AB TWELVE FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN
TO COMMENT ON AB TWELVE FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME MANY QUESTIONS FOR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. AREA THE
AUTHOR MAY CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR HELP. BUT I THINK MISTER
MATTHEWS IS THE FIRST IN MISS
DAVIS IS SECOND YEAH. DAVIES
SORRY FOR THAT- AND- MANTA
CRITICAL ROLE. MOTION IS TO
PASS TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SANTIAGO HI
SANTIAGO I'D PATTERSON. LISTEN
ONLINE BOERNER HORVATH BONTA
CERVANTES DAVIES DAVIES NINE
EDUARDO GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA I
HOLDEN HOLDEN I LOVE. LOW I
COOK SILVA- SILVA AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ SIGNED MATHIS. MATHIS
I'D CARILLO. NINE ZERO MEASURES
OUT THEY GIVE A GOOD GROUP OF
BILL BUT I DO WANT TO WELCOME I
SHOULD ON THIS EARLIER BUT WHEN
WE STARTED SUBCOMMITTEE BUT
ONLY A COUPLE PEOPLE HERE
MISTER THIS PATTERSON THE
DEVICE TO THE COMMITTEES THAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING
US I WILL PROP PROBABLY WILL BE
ALONE. AND THE. AND ALLOW LIVE
CALL IN THE BILLS AND ADAMS AS
WELL. I'VE BEEN NUMBER ONE ON
CALL AB FOURTEEN ANGULAR CURRY
CURRENT VOTE IS. SIX ONE. BONTA
BOERNER HORVATH. HOLDEN. HOLDEN
I. RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I. EIGHT
TO ONE MEASURES OUT.
I WILL DO
THAT ON THEM. I'M NUMBER TWO AB
ELEVEN HUNDRED I GET A CURRY.
FILE ITEMS. BOERNER HORVATH
BONTA. BONTA I. RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I. NINE TWO. HI
NUMBER THREE AB SIX SIX ZERO
COOPER. PATTERSON PATTERSON I
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BONTA I
HOLDEN HOLDEN I RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I. TWELVE ZERO. I
DON'T KNOW BEFORE AB THIRTEEN
FORTY NINE MATHIS. BONTA BONTA
I HOLDEN HOLDEN I RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I YEAH. TWELVE ZERO.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE FOURTEEN
TWENTY SIX MATHIS.
BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I BONTA BONTA%
AYE HOLDEN HOLDEN I RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ AYE CORREA. TWELVE
TWO ZERO. HI THE NUMBER SIX AB
THIRTY FORMER SU CHI. PATTERSON
PATTERSON NOT VOTING. BONTA
BONTA I. HOLDEN HOLDEN I COOK
SILVA. QUICKSILVER I. ELEVEN
TWO ZERO. I NUMBER SEVEN AB
FORTY ONE WORD. BONTA BONTA I.
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ SIGNED.
ELEVEN ONE. HI THE NUMBER EIGHT
TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN PATTISON.
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
I BONTA BONTA I CERVANTES.
CORREA. ELEVEN TWO ZERO. ON THE
COMMITTEE RULES. PATTERSON
PATTERSON I BOERNER HORVATH
BOERNER HORVATH I BONTA BONTA I
HOLDEN HOLDEN I RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ SIGH. THE WITH
ANOTHER. WHERE TO GO THROUGH
ONE MORE TIME FOR THE MOST OF
YOU GUYS APART DONE
EVERYTHING'S DONE I THINK.
ORDER. I NUMBER ONE FOR ADULTS
AB FOURTEEN ANGULAR CURRY
BOERNER HORVATH. BUT A WHOLE
FENNEL VOTING. BONTA BONTA I.
FINAL VOTE IS. NINE ONE. I
NUMBER TWO AB ELEVEN HUNDRED
ANGULAR CURRY. BOERNER HORVATH
BUT ALL BOERNER HORVATH I.
FINAL VOTE IS TEND. TO HI THE
NUMBER THREE AB SIX SIX ZERO
COOPER BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I. FINAL VOTE
IS. THIRTEEN ZERO. I AM NUMBER
FOUR AB THIRTEEN FORTY NINE
MATHIS. CORREA I FINAL VOTE IS.
THIRTEEN ZERO. ADAM NUMBER FIVE
AB FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX MATHIS.
COREA COREA I FINAL VOTE.
THIRTEEN ZERO. A. B. THIRTY
FOUR- SU CHI ITEM NUMBER SIX
FINAL VOTE IS. ELEVEN ZERO. THE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB FORTY ONE
MR WORD. FINAL VOTE IS. ELEVEN
ONE. I NUMBER EIGHT TWELVE
FIFTY SEVEN PATTISON. CERVANTES
CORREA I. FINAL VOTE IS TWELVE
ZERO.
ALL THE EVERYBODY DONE
WE'RE JUST TALKING THANKS.
HILLARY CUTTERS ABOUT THE
FINANCING. JUST LET HIM KNOW
JUST ONE OF OUR LARGE CAP OFF
EVERYBODY.
NO I'M GONNA. I AM
NUMBER SIX A. B. THIRTY FORMER
SU CHI VOTER CHANGE PATTERSON
FROM NOT VOTE IN PATTERSON FOR
NOT VOTING TO KNOW. FINAL VOTE
IS.
ELEVEN ONE. WE'RE JOINING
COMMITTEE. WELL.